hello everybody hello hello i'm back and i'm going to play a
video game say it ain't so my oh she is playing video games
it has been a while since i gamed guys i i legit don't even
i was just like how do i how do i stream games again i i
just want no way
ball commentary wait wait she's a gamer
let me give you say let me write this write something down
real quick um and it's not related to any balls or guns or
pal world i was like looking at my looking at like like ever
since i came back from l.a it's never been the same on it.
It's like, um, it's like, I'm like a different dokeyverse
that stumbled my way into this dokeyverse.
It's like Rick and Morty were, I, uh, it's like a, we got
the wrong dokey back.
Ever since I came back from LA, it's just, it's just been
ball and gun and pow world.
Uh, my, my two fit, my three favorite games, balls, guns and
pow, world.
Betty, thank you for super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I didn't know about oh, she was a nerd.
See you later, chump.
High fives of my boys on the way up.
I'm like a pod person.
They groomed me in LA.
Old Doki is still enjoying her vacation right now in LA.
There was a switch in the Doki for his daycare.
Alright, let me let me know that the server is up now.
server is back up I think yeah it's back up so she should be
good to go to get in on it what else what kind of life
updates that okay so for those who don't know um I'm like my
brain is actually I'm like oh my gosh I'm it's I don't know
I'm trying to remember how to stream right now
but I got really burnt out last week because i might have
taken too much stuff too much work um so my social battery
is very very very low as you guys can tell when my schedule
came up on wednesday um so um basically i did two
conventions two panels two meeting greets um a collab right
after like uh the the wildcard club collab during my rest
day and then another and then a stream at 10 in the morning
that was also a collab um so i was very very very very tired
you know like uh thank you for the raid thank you thank you
so like it was like i think it was also because i had to
talk to a lot of people um yeah i might have pushed myself a
little too hard uh but i love talking to my dragons i love
talking to my friends and everything but as an introvert i
might have like it was like i was like at zero percent
battery and i was just like like i was like don't worry
there's still juice left in her guys don't worry let me just
shake it a little bit more there's it's okay there's it
might say zero percent but there's actually 0.5 percent left
of the battery let me just whack it a little bit let me yeah
i was just like don't worry we can squeeze a little bit out
more like yeah it's because i even did uh i even did like
yeah it's like getting like buy a new tooth like not trying
to buy a new toothpaste and you're just don't wait there's
still a little bit more toothpaste left to me yeah um yeah
and so even the meet and greet at off kai was a bonus thing
um it was literally like uh my events manager was like the
day before off-cloud was like, do you want to do a meeting
grade off-cloud?
We can set it up at the Noms Cafe booth.
And I was just like, do I, do I have enough energy?
And I was like, oh, that's Future Doki's problem.
Future Doki would have enough energy because when she asked
me, I did not have energy.
But I was just like, I think Future Doki would have the, she
did not.
She did.
I was just like, maybe by the time it's that day, she's
going to have that energy.
Yeah.
So, I did, of course, I would love meeting you guys at all.
Like, I love meeting you guys.
And I always love doing these things.
But I definitely overworked myself there because I did a lot
of social stuff.
Like, and I did, like, an artist alley walkaround as well.
As well as, I did two walkarounds, basically, because we
didn't have a lot of time.
Like, I said, I was fully booked up.
Like, I still wanted to stream because I have, I felt like,
you know, I've been traveling a lot.
uh for work and everything so I feel like I have haven't
been streaming as much I still wanted to stream despite all
these events I still wanted to stream for you guys and
everything so even during the conventions the panels the
meeting greets um the collabs and everything I still wanted
to stream for you guys on those days and so I had not a lot
of time I even had to do I did like the wildcard club um I
did the wildcard club uh walk around as well at the booth
there because we didn't have time to do the wildcard club
walk around and artist alley at the same time so i was just
like all right um so my manager was like my events manager
was like um on day one like thursday uh she was like oh just
do the walk around for wildcard club and then um and then
we'll just stop from there and then we'll do the artist
alley stuff um another like we'll do the artist alley stuff
uh on sunday and i was like yeah that's cool and i only had
an hour on sunday walked like 10 percent of apparently there
was a hundred uh plus booths that were at off guy that was
selling dokey merch and i was only able to do 10 of them um
so i'm really sorry if i didn't get to see some of the
artists there uh i legit after the like i only had i could
only do it before the panel which was at i don't remember
which was at 12 so i woke up at um 10 in the morning um prep
for i woke up 10 in the morning because we were supposed to
prep for the panel at 11 so i woke up at 10 did the artist
alley walk for an hour and then went to the paddle prep that
11 and then streamed at 12 and then obviously on tuesday i
had to wake up at 10 in the morning to do the uh post off
pie wildcard club announcement with amalie moussey and rin
as well on that day and so like um i obviously because like
i already used my sunday up i used to do sunday and monday
for my off days just to fully recharge like do back-to-back
recharge days because i year like that's like you know i i
know i like to put all my recharge days on like back to back
just so i can like fully recover it but like i went sunday i
only had monday and wednesday to basically rest up um post
everything yeah i was so tired i was so fucking tired um and
uh i felt so bad because a lot of people wanted to talk to
me and take photos while i was doing the walk around and was
just like Doki cannot stop I'm so sorry like I was I thought
I was like I'm sorry like the like he's he was just like
sorry we we have to get through the artist Sally we can't
stop for a conversation and meaning like impromptu meaning
greets and photos guys are so sorry the artist can the
artist got the photos and everything because I love talking
like you know because the artists worked really like you
know the artists are you know are uh I'm really honored for
artists to draw me and draw me and make merch of me so of
course like you know this is like my return just to be like
hey thank you so much for uh for drawing me i would love to
buy your stuff and everything so you know i gave i talked to
the artists 101 and also like uh like you know if they
wanted photos and everything like i really appreciate
artists like you know as a vtuber you can't really do what
you do about the hard work of the artists behind you so i
always love supporting artists and like you know buying
merch of me they always be like you want anything else just
me no it's okay i just want to buy merch of me like i only
me i'm my own biggest fan yosh thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you don't keep being social i vent to the
point of burn blames on her pass off our oshi everybody
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i'm i'm
only here for b i'm i'm here for my oshi uh miss dokeybird
uh so that's why i'm i i'm i was i was really tired oh yeah
for those who are wondering when i'm going to play post like
the references and everything uh of my new of my new outfit
i know i haven't posted yet like i said i'm getting a lot of
like work done like post uh so they just kind of came back
from offkai and everything so we're just getting like little
correct like little i guess like uh what's it called what's
that word called like um makeover a little bit like clean up
wanted to fix and clean up that we weren't able to do uh
before the outfit reveal so i wanted to get all of that
retouched like you know like i wanted to have like um black
nail polish on as like the default uh so like my fingernails
are really bare right now because we're still having we
still haven't painted our fingernails during the sleepover
guys oh my god that means i've got to do another sleepover
so we can like paint each other's nails and everything guys
uh so um Like small things like that and also fix the hair a
little bit and everything.
I don't remember all the notes, all the notes I wrote down
about like what I'm changing, like what I'm touching up and
fixing.
So that's why I haven't posted the reference.
There isn't really a reference sheet.
It's just screenshots of the full skin suit on Twitter yet.
Because I know like usually I do that post outfit reveal,
but we haven't yet.
That's because I'm just waiting for the cleanup, like just
to...
cleanup post cleanup and some minor fixes that i want to do
uh well thank you for the super chat thank you i don't think
that's healthy yeah you think we can get more detailed
references for future um i usually think like just the
screenshots of the skin suits itself just sort of does this
trick because like there's not really nothing i'm sort of
hiding like that that like a reference she would just is i
felt like would just be telling like i felt like um there's
nothing really new that needs a reference sheet to tell the
full story of the outfit that's why i was just i just post
the um the screenshots itself um what else i want to talk
about i'm trying to remember like what oh yeah i played
rocore fine like i did a i did rocore um i did very much i
enjoy ro i did and uh because i wanted to play that try that
game out for a while and i will say i can tell why it's
mixed reviews but those who don't know rogue core is deep
rock galactic but like what if it's a roguelike and you know
i love roguelike and everything um and uh and it's just it's
literally just deep rock galactic but like guns and
power-ups are roguelike and yet they're like farm harm gems
to upgrade your builds and everything and I think I don't I
didn't read the reviews but it's mixed reviews and it's
still in beta it's open beta right now it's not like fully
out yet I can see why people give mixed reviews because the
I think it's a game where you cannot solo because I did a
solo run of it uh I did a solo run of it and it was so
fucking hard because I I enjoyed the game and then they were
like I gotta go now So I kept trying to play it solo.
I legitimately it was so fucking hard like And like I was
playing the hardest difficulty too with my friend and it
wasn't like like I was playing the hardest difficulty with
my friend And I did standard mode on solo and I was just
like this is not worth like I was just like I'm not having
fun like i was just like i i like it it was so brutal it was
so fucking brutal because the swarm this is the swarm of
like monsters is not like what's the word um they're not
kind to you at all like and the boss fights are fucking hard
even if you're like i think you have to play it as a full
stack you can't play it as like the boss fights like like
even i thought had a really yeah it's not balanced very well
for like solo slash duo runs yep um and uh and so when i try
to do duos with my friend and do like we did the hardest
difficulty on boss runs like it felt like we were doing
really really well until uh until we got to the boss fights
and then like i we just got destroy it like legit like he
shot one like the monster shot one bullet at us and we
fucking died
just like and legitimately because like we were doing okay
until we got to a certain point of the game like the other
the other bosses they were hard but like they weren't like
i'm gonna fucking destroy you and like your fear like you'll
never like end your ancestors like i'm gonna wipe your
And yeah, and then, but then we got to this one boss that
legitimately just looked at us and we just disappeared from
existence as if like we never existed.
And I was like, I'm not playing anymore.
I, I was just like, I'm done.
Like I legit, I got my fix, you know, I was like, after two
days, I was just like, I'm done.
I don't, I don't need to play more Rookcore anymore.
I, because the power scaling was just fucking ridiculous.
why it was mixed reviews because i had fun until we got to
the point where like where where it just felt like other
bullshit like there's no like game plan around it yeah we
were just erased from the history books um all right what
else what else i want to talk about but but but um let's see
uh oh yes did you guys i tweeted about it and i really want
to talk about but did you guys see the fucking antichrist
that america's building right now uh for search and rescue
robots um i talked i tweeted about it because even i was
like this has to be like satire this can't be fucking real
you can tell they spent millions of dollars developing this
too so i'll show you guys a picture of it oh yeah at seven i
have to go uh because oh yeah i forgot to tell tell you guys
this but i thought this was like satire um but um a u.s uh
robot developing agency is making new robots for search and
rescue so like your initial thought must have been like i
hope it's friend shaped like you know you're fucking dying
because it's like the specialty is wildfires rebel searches
toxic areas and confined spaces so you know you would think
it'd be friend shaped because if you're fucking dying or
you're like at the verge of death and you and you know you
would want to like you would want to give them a nice image
of like who their rescuers are but instead what we got i i i
literally thought this was like satire or like like from
like the onion or some share like disgust like disgusting
now not so this was like the first image i saw from this
tweet because I legit thought this was a fucking joke and so
um yeah it's like a half it's a centaur slash goat head like
and a goat by the way and it's fully black like it came from
like the depths of hell like they just burnt this guy like
and like what the fuck is with the eyes does it
Imagine if like, if like you're stuck in a while, like
you're still, you, you're, an earthquake just happened.
You're in the rubble and this is the first thing.
Like I would thought I died.
Like I'm like in the, like the fifth circle of hell.
Like that thing should be, has this like an SNL sketch or
some shit.
If friend wise hate the chip, that person, thank you for the
super chat.
Thank you.
And like, and then, you know, you're like, okay.
so and then because you're like one of their tasks is to do
like wildfires like do like search and rescue for wildfires
so like their fucking great idea for this is to give the
robot a fucking chainsaw as if that's gonna help anything
like why would you give it a fucking chainsaw like and by
the way this is human remote controlled so it's not like an
actual AI or whatever so if this is remote controlled by a
human why the fuck does it look like this like and also yo
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you but it's
purged as abomination from the warp thank you for the super
chat why did they make the devil why did they add horns why
why did they add horns and then you know what was so funny
apparently um apparently one of the notes was that uh was
that maybe they were like one of the key features is that
the robot cannot fit through a standard door frame if the
large demonic horns are installed why does it need large
demonic horns like this is like one of the one of the notes
that they wrote um so i guess it's like if you want to stop
it from going through doorways make sure to install the
fucking devil horns so you'll be safe from the goat monster
like not just let me die bro it's called brand yes the horns
are apparently to protect us and so it can't go through
doors like i did why why do we need the horns
Frozen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Me waiting for the light to end up done, only for it to be
eyes of the dear Satan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Cyber, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Not just let me die, bro.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This feels like an enemy from Ultra Kill.
It's how it feels.
Thank you.
Like, I don't understand.
I think why is it not friend shaped?
Like, oh, you might as well make the eyes red.
Oh, yeah.
And then apparently you can put a gun.
You can store your guns in it.
Like, they have pockets to store your guns.
so all right there's air reservoir and graphics of a lot of
the location of the e-stop sensors so you might need to go
to stop the terrifying inhuman so there's a sensor there so
you do need to stop it you just gotta wave your hat in front
of the chest and be like stop
That's where you wave your hand to be like, stop.
Just in case you have to stop it.
But what if he doesn't?
Who thought this guy?
I don't know who designed.
The fact that they gave him a fucking chainsaw is a fucking
wild.
Stop.
Stephen, but back away.
Oh, if you stop it.
Oh, if you stop or stop, then like, what's the point if he's
so easy to stop?
Like, if you just, if you need to stop him, remember to stab
him in the heart, guys.
Guys, this is the only way to disable the spawn of Satan.
Make sure you stab the robot.
in the heart yeah that's it's a boss fight and that's its
weak point don't forget to parry the ghost steven yeah holy
shit yeah that's what i wanted to update you like this is
like like world update um we're we're at this we are
this we are born in this period of time where we have search
and rescue demon spawns uh this yeah twitter dudes are
joking by the way uh that's where we are at like we we might
have um not born during the time um at least we're you know
i don't even know how we can compare this like we are born
in the period where we're inventing demon spawn search and
rescue robots uh what a crazy thing to do what a crazy time
to be alive bro it's a monster from the ritual also welcome
back doki happy to say that your body beat a merch and quote
yeah i'm glad i'm glad you received the merch crossfire
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um how are
all thank you the super chat thank you thank you clearly
knew and we're leading into it thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you We're not born in the time.
Born too early before flying cars.
Born too late before the gold rush.
But at least born just in time for demon robots.
Okay.
Just in time.
The one...
All right.
Anyway, today we're playing finally.
times we scheduled this game.
We're playing Ratcoin.
Coin, pusher, rogue-like.
I've been meaning to play this game for a very, very...
I don't know.
I think I scheduled this game like three times.
And we finally...
We're finally able to play this for real.
I don't know if Sound Guy is alive, but let me...
Alright, let's see.
Let me put this up.
Ratcoin.
There are so many games I've like... This is one of those
games where I kept scheduling it and then we weren't...
We keep like delaying it the once a year game stream let's
go oh yes forgot to mention like i said i'm actually taking
a real vacation um next week i'm sorry i know i've been like
traveling a lot disappearing in and out a lot as well but um
you know we've today this year has been a lot of traveling
joki going around um i mean got invited by capcon um i'll
tell you guys right now later in august i will be traveling
again but this one's a lot shorter it's like a three-day
trip uh because i got uh invited by capcom to check out
their studio uh so that's why i will also not be there at
the later half of august because of it but next week i will
be taking a vacation next week um the one in uh not not in
japan i'm not going to capcom japan so um it's uh it's like
in the states Um, our music can come down a little bit.
Alright, let me, we'll reduce flashing just for it so no one
can get, uh, what's the word, epilepsy.
You know, I'm out looking out for you guys out there.
The little guys out there.
Um, make sure everything is good.
I'll turn it down right now.
Um, what else I want to say?
So I will be gone, um, for a couple of days, but I will be
back on the 7th, uh, for a collab sponsor with Stuffy.
So I'll be back on the 7th, so I'm really sorry that I've
been sort of traveling a lot, disappearing a lot this year.
But like I said, a lot of very fun, exciting things I've
been doing this year as well.
So I know it's a sacrifice with less streams in general.
But we have a lot more fun events, more fun projects going
on because in exchange for that, it's a lot more bigger
stuff going on versus just the smaller streams and
everything.
okay everybody this year is like i this year has been the
most i've ever traveled ever flown around like i've flown
and traveled so much this year compared to the last 10 years
of my life uh so so it has been a wild 2026 and only halfway
through 2026 so yeah i i swear i've flown more just this in
this year alone than i have within the last 10 years um so i
really appreciate everybody And I just really need a
vacation next week.
I was so tired.
I think I just pushed myself way too hard.
And I've actually rescheduled this vacation three different
times.
So I've been, um, I felt really bad because, um, and I
promised myself that this, the third time, I will not
reschedule it.
Oh, wait, the fourth time.
I rescheduled this vacation three separate times.
Um, because something always came up during that day.
week that I have to like I want I was about to take this
vacation like I paid for like all the stuff and everything
and I pushed it back three separate times and the next week
I was just like I'm gonna take it like I had to decline a
sponsor slash event because I was just like I I cannot
reschedule this a fourth time I was just like I felt so bad
I was just like I cannot I cannot
I have to I have to I have to take it okay set the pixel
size all right do we want more pixely or I feel like
standard just so like that's where it should be playing as
so um coin pusher I would say coin pusher is like baby's
first oh my god ramen all right um let it ride oh let it
ride
Okay, I will say, also SoundGuard, let me know if
everything's okay, or if I need to edit it a bit, edit the
settings a bit more.
Let it rip.
Here are the sound of everything.
Let me double check the, you know what, 100 and no limit.
Let me see the coins.
Let me see the coins dropping 800 frames per second, as it
should be.
Okay.
Give me those frames.
Let me see those frames drop.
Yeah, drop those frames.
Unlimited frames.
Let's go.
All right, auto and round pause.
Oh, apparently this is roguelike, too.
Let it rid.
All right.
Let's go.
So, I'm going to play about any flashy power-ups.
Our flag coming back in for more fun.
So, we want to play about any just like the real one.
Okay, then.
Lab.
I will go with normal.
All right.
Owners.
Start the tutorial as this character.
Let the sweet raccoon order guide you.
Teach us you how to play the game.
Manager.
Mastering using.
All right.
We got to.
I don't know how to play.
this game so we gotta do the tutorial again uh uh green
difficulty a baby card a tutorial for beginners all right
play all right so um i've grown up with coin pushers for
this you don't know uh coin pusher machines are like baby's
first gambling machines because like in asia okay i don't
know like in na because like it was called was it u.s
genasium what is it called this was like a really popular
machine in hong kong um like sorry really popular arcade
thing in hong kong i think it was called uh i'm trying to
remember exactly what it was called it was called jumping
gym usa arcade so um my parents would take it was basically
like the david busters of hong kong or asia
with going to the jumping gym USA arcade machines in Hong
Kong.
And the thing about these coin pushers is like baby's first
slot machine.
So you would see coin pusher machines a lot in these like
arcades made for kids because like gambling, obviously,
yeah, be 18.
Like a lot of arcades and everything, yeah.
Like especially for some reason, like in Asia, a lot of
arcades are 18 plus only like you can't go into an arcade
unless you're 18 so there's like kid arcades and stuff
specifically for children under 18 and so uh because like
coin pushers was sort of like sort of like slots machines
but instead of getting you can get like coins like from the
to play more or tickets uh and stuff for for these and it
was really funny because um you can see a lot of like i
talked about this story before but like all the elderly like
all the elderly were just camping around these machines
because it's like you know it's like casinos where a lot of
like the grandpas and grandmas are just at the slots
machines so you like all you'd see like like all the coin
pushing machines in this like kid arcade this children's
arcade was just like frequented by like the elderly and they
Yeah, yeah, so like, you know, it's just all, kids are
playing all the other stuff and then, like, the grannies and
grandpas were just playing on the coin pushers, and they
would have this, like, giant plastic bag that just holds all
the tickets, and they would just camp on these machines, and
it, yeah, yeah, and so it was like, I thought it was really
funny, I gotta get herself a, gotta get herself a rice
cooker, um, and I was thinking of Super Chat, Thank you.
Doki is taking vacations and doing tutorials.
What's going on, Dragoons help?
I will say it does give you a rush as a child when you hit
the jackpot on the coin push.
When you, like, put it in the right area and then, like, you
see all those coins push.
Like, they know how to get you.
They started, like, they get you young.
I played, I did play a lot of the coins.
Yeah, when you see all those coins fall and they hit the
jackpot and then they start spitting out more coins at you.
Oh, they know how to, God, teach them, God, get them young.
you know yeah it's it fires all the synapses in my brain
yeah rush of dopamine and torpins yeah
all right it's built from it looks rough but it's fully
functional insert copper coins come out of these shoots a
corn and serious lies to the other side i want to try it's
much more fun when you play with yourself you have 20 coins
now anyone cooks right without a rice cooker is a neon on
dango thank you thank you thank you i told this story before
but when i was with my grandma at the jumping gym uh usa
arcade there are these like games where you throw a coin so
there is these games where you throw a coin it has to land
on these squares like there was like these rainbows on this
like floor and it has to land on if you can land at the very
center you win a grand prize or something like that so you
just throw coins and see where it lands and like rolls
around there's one of those and then there was another one
where it was like you have to land on these like little
platforms and stuff.
And then my grandma won the grand prize.
And then like, by the way, in these arcades, there's like
crazy shit there, like practical stuff.
You can get vacuum, vacuums, like cooking utensils.
Like you can get like real adult shit, like like house
stuff, like appliances and everything, not just like things
for kids.
There's like, you can get literally appliances, iPads,
iPhone, all that shit.
So my grandma threw her coin And she got the grand prize,
where you can pick anything up there, like all the
appliances and everything.
And she fucking picked a rice cooker.
Because she was like, it's useful.
But my grandma was like, I won you a rice cooker.
Like to my mom's daughter.
And her mom was just like, mom, I have a rice cooker.
And she's like, yes, but this one's free.
I was just like, oh, grandma, grandma, you should get, you
should get the iPad, grandma, you should get the iPad, and
she's like, I know what I'm gonna get, I'm gonna get the
rice cooker.
Simple mind, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
I was like, you should get the Nintendo, I don't even
remember if Nintendo Switch was around during that time.
I was like, you should get the Wii, grandma.
You should get the Wii U, grandma.
And she's like, I know what I'm gonna get.
And Doki never forgave grandma a rice cooker.
You should get the giant ass plushie.
Look how big that plushie is.
And if she got the rice, I'll never forgive her for picking
the rice cooker in front of me.
I was so happy for us.
For us.
Because I was part of this deal.
Because if I was and there she would not have gone to the
arcade she i i was so proud of us for winning that grand
prize because i wanted to play this game and we won this uh
um uh simple minded thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you we had a bunch of these at our festival when i was
They used to give you quarters, but they had to change a
token so kids could play it.
They give a super chat.
Thank you.
Our victory.
Papa, thank you.
The super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't you never forgive Grandma rice cooker.
And I've held a grudge since related to rice cookers.
Um, um, Patra said they give a super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, grandma said, what's good is apple that you cannot eat,
but rice cooker feeds family for generations.
Alright, let's see.
I guess we can just...
Can I just press...
Oh, wait.
Oh.
There we go.
Okay, so it's E and...
I'm gonna grab here.
It's because we're...
Oh, yeah!
Yeah!
Alright, alright, alright, alright.
I'm gonna focus.
Actually, I can do both sides.
Oh, look at all those coins drop.
Oh, look at all those coins.
drop scoring tickets this shows how many tickets you have a
coin is the right now reach the target score to clear this
round it feels too fast or two so you can use these buttons
to adjust the speed oh there's more oh it doesn't stop I'll
do both sides to optimize it too all right oh it's still
going on oh I reached the goal already
It doesn't matter.
I still want to keep going.
Okay.
Oh, we're going to win big.
Nice.
You hit the target.
All right.
Let's enter a shop to end this round.
I know, pussy.
I saw six more.
Keep going.
Wait, do I not gain any more?
Oh, I do.
You want me to just stop?
I still have so many coins.
we don't quit never give up let it rid all right nice oh
okay more extra tickets all right now we can enter the shop
we don't give up that's how they get you oh yeah we're not
allowed to put a lot of the machines would be installed with
like the anti-push so start being like like they'll start
ringing alarms and stuff and be like
Step away from the coin pusher machine, child.
Step away from the coin pusher machines.
Yeah, the anti-shake technology.
Put your hands up for the crime of shaking.
You can spend tickets to buy items in the shop.
Check out our wide range of special coins.
Each has unique effects.
How do you know that?
Why not buy them all?
What are they?
one oh excuse me oh because they're rabbits okay that's
crazy oh my god but now it can only hold two don't worry
let's expand it all right expand it her right horizontally
all right now it holds up why not take the last coin i want
to see uh explosion oh and then is destroyed okay all right
My coins are going to start banging, I guess.
Alright.
At the start of each round.
Now continue stirring copper coins.
How do I...
Okay.
Alright, let's try this out.
Oh, silver coin.
How did I get here?
How did my silver coin get here?
Oh, whoops.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, wait, that's my...
realize if i put throw them out at the same time how do i oh
i can use them usable now how do i use it okay so you being
used right now
all right i want to try getting the middle out because the
middle has like stuff out there too all right then i will
put these two out there i did click on it but i didn't do
anything yet.
Alright, I won't get that silver coin out closer.
Oh, I only have four.
Oh.
Nice.
Now, slam those two together to after.
Oh, that's a lot of coin drop right there.
Oh, yeah!
Okay, exchange.
The dots below, showing me remaining exchanges you have.
Okay.
Now the special coins They'll be thrown through the central
shoot Try using all of your special coins Oh now I can use
it Okay Oh Okay the special coins have to touch each other
So I gotta make sure Alright yeah Yeah
Alright Alright
Um All right, that's fine.
Okay, whoops.
All right.
That's right.
It's just that easy.
The birds and the bees.
All right.
Let's put more coins in here.
Okay, we got to exchange more.
Seven tickets equals another.
Whoa!
All right, guys.
I think I got it.
Okay, we can get more coins, though.
let it ride we don't stop never give up okay i want to push
all the coins from this side oh that's a lot too
actual boom town okay we have pushed all of these closer
becomes weak coins all right we can enter shop now uh you'll
buy all the coins all right but oh i should have read what
that is nearby each kill plus 20 what's a bad coin you can
buy chips now chance for coins to get plus one when scored
uh plus eight initials all right oh okay so i have two four
okay i have five they're like my little boosters uh enter
next round bad coins oh that's what oh bad coins drive out
good ones it's uh bad coin this time they restrict you from
exchanging for you better clear the bad coin app.
Try inserting.
Okay, we gotta insert this then.
Okay, whoops.
Alright, nice.
Nice.
Okay, got him just in time.
That's because raccoon kills bad coins.
The more you understand, the coins affect each other, the
more options you have.
Alright.
Okay, nice.
Alright, we're gonna put another parrot in there.
Oh, oh!
Yes!
Touch it!
Start fucking!
Don't you hate it when your coins just start banging each
other?
Like, God, I'm so happy for you.
God, I know, isn't that so annoying when your coins just
start reproducing in your machine?
I sure do hate it.
And then they make me watch, too.
Like, God, please get a fucking room, guys.
Yeah, I'm trying to get that silver coin in there.
Okay, oh my god, it's like all the way there!
Come on, give me those 10 coins!
I'm tired, you so tired.
No!
Alright, we're going to put an explosion right here.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
All right, nice.
We got a coin there.
All right.
Plus three.
I can change.
Oh, shit.
All right, nice.
Yeah, I don't think I can push the...
I'm going to focus on the left side more.
Just because I have a lot of investment.
Oh, actually, there's some stuff here, too.
Okay, that should...
Come on.
Oh, it was so close.
fine.
I have enough tickets.
Come on.
We're so close.
Yes!
One more!
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Goal achieve.
Okay, we're gonna put that here.
Alright, now.
Alright, keep going.
Oh, there's so much.
Look at that.
Look at all of that.
Wait, prizes.
Oh, I don't have any yet.
Alright, now.
Oh, nice.
You cleared up backwards.
Choose a keychain.
Retain unused coins minus 20% plus one prize slot.
I feel like shop prices.
After clearing bad coins, you can pick keychain.
Either, guys, prize slot or shop coupon.
I feel like shop coupon, right?
So I can save more money.
Or...
Also, has sound guys?
Sound been okay so far?
I don't...
I feel like shop.
Like, long term wise.
Okay.
Okay, provide that lasts the entire run.
Yeah, I'm gonna do the shop.
Alright, nice.
We'll buy more.
Adds another one additional.
Same coin to be stored.
Now you can buy prize that must be activated manually.
Your most purchased coin.
Rain.
Oh, give me that.
Okay, bad coin.
Hunt's the most valuable.
What the fuck?
He's just gonna eat my coins?
Okay, let's buy.
Bob.
I don't have a...
Alright, let's see.
We're gonna make it rid.
Uh, next coin will be after six.
These are lucky stuff.
Uh, on exchange obtain, uh, random coin, a chocolate box.
Uh, we'll buy this.
And then, oh, I can buy more.
I'll buy this too.
Just keep expanding.
Alright, let's go.
I tried using the prize rain bag.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's...
Oh!
All right.
The higher the combo, the higher the score rate.
Get a high enough combo to light up the spin energy bar.
Uh, you have one spin.
Oh my god, this is where they start raining, right?
Oh my god, this is where the coins start raining.
Oh, this is where the jackpot!
Wait, 20.
That's a lot.
That's a lot of coins!
Yes!
Those coins are getting extra frisky.
Oh my god, yes!
Keep going!
I don't stop make all the kids
Holy shit they're all just okay Oh, I got so many silver
coins there too Alright, I can actually start I can use
these too Come on, come on, yes, yes Start banging Come on,
I can put another one Oh, come on, come on Your soulmate is
down there Yeah Yeah Oh my god.
Oh, and again.
And again.
Just keep at it.
We're all here to like get pregnant.
We're all here to watch.
In front of a live studio audience.
Oh my god.
All right.
And again.
That's what we paid to see, I guess.
Oh my god.
And another spin.
Oh, 50!
Grandma's going to find another rice cooker.
And then everyone claps.
Whoa.
All right, nice.
Oh, wait, do I get another spin?
I think I got another spin after this.
Oh my god, it doesn't stop spinning.
Oh my god, 32 combos.
Do another spin.
And another one.
Oh my god.
And another spin.
Another 25.
My god keeps going.
The combo that never...
And I got another spin.
Let it rid.
Oh my god.
One more.
And another.
Oh,
did I hear another spin?
Oh, wait, it might be stuck here right now.
Unless, oh, oh, oh, oh, it was hot.
Just a little bit more.
It was hot, no, we were so close.
Oh, never mind.
It's still going.
I just can't.
Oh, my God.
And another 25.
Can she be?
stopped oh my god let's just you know what fucking let's
just throw an explosion here for fun too you know just just
a little treat
oh come on we just need one more come on don't hold out on
me like that don't hold out all right i think it's over i i
think i think we got it all right okay horizontal vertical
let's just i mean we can we can afford it and draws in coins
fuck it let's go on it 25 percent chance of getting fuck it
just buy it all that's convert nearby coins oh my god and
another bunny oh my god We're so rich, it doesn't even
matter!
Alright.
You know what?
Let's grab, let's grab more stuff!
When scored, plus 20?
Oh, yeah!
Let's see, plus 15.
Fuck it, let's go!
Combo won't break.
Oh, yeah!
This was the final run.
They can't do this to me.
They can't just hold out.
What do you mean the final run?
Oh, my God.
They can't do this to me.
They can't just...
No!
Draws, the coins.
Okay, wait.
Oh my god.
Yes!
Oh!
Fucking send it all in!
I don't even know what's going on.
Just everything.
Fuck it.
Let's keep on going.
I have four spins.
Oh my.
God combo 85 never stop oh my god does that say 168 I'm
waiting oh it's the tower of coins let's
see fuck it just drop that in I might as well what What the
fuck is that?
How do I even use it?
How do I...
How do I tip the tower?
Oh, I have to...
Wait, I'm gonna... I'm gonna try...
We're gonna try to tip the tower.
We're gonna try it out.
Okay.
I can't even see in front of me.
I hope it's working.
I...
No!
All right, one more exchange.
One more exchange.
It'll be worth it, guys.
It'll be so worth it.
Guys, it'll be so worth it when we tip the tower.
Oh my god.
Why is it just there?
We gotta get this.
If we get this, we can get this entire stack.
Guys, guys, trust the process.
If we get this, we can get all...
Just think, just think.
We just need to get this.
And then we can suck the tower.
If only she had.
How was I supposed to know?
Trust the process, guys.
Come on.
Yes.
Oh, it's getting closer.
It's getting closer.
I don't know what happened to it.
I threw everything in it.
And for some reason, that was not the right thing to do.
who would have known come on it's almost oh my god it's
almost there oh my god we got it where is it oh my god right
here yes yes yes okay I told you trust the process oh my god
Oh my god.
It's all silver.
We can't stop now.
Look at this collection of silver coins
Okay, wait oh Oh my god, we're so up Okay Look at that look
at all it just never stops.
It just doesn't stop.
Oh, and And I'm going to get a prize ball.
Oh my god.
Guys, I can't stop the run now.
Wait, I get another black hole too.
And a black hole?
Okay, wait, I'll exchange another one.
Oh, I'm out of...
No!
No, they can't just bait me with five prize balls.
Well, I think this is where they kick me out of the arcade,
guys.
I, they're like, grandma's, the arcade closed three hours
ago, grandma.
You have to leave.
No!
We can't.
Oh, my gosh.
It's close.
It's time to go home.
It's fine.
The fish did not matter.
I can't believe they kicked me out.
Why?
I wasn't done.
We should paint the scenery for all of the stuff that's
happening.
Alright.
Now for a real game.
We're gonna call the cops so you don't leave.
you out of the facilities uh paper card one exchange
refitted by chips are these like uh bonuses all right we're
gonna play here all right i need to turn on the aircon hi
it's so hot in my room i'll be back i don't know all that
winning has got me asked up and
it got me heated up winning all of those games
I've just...
Whoa, I've been on fire!
Alright.
We're gonna start with these guys over here.
Slow and steady.
Oh!
Not as slow as I thought it was gonna be, I guess.
Alright.
Oh my god.
okay we'll focus on the other side now and that is we gotta
use it all
all right it's time to retain the rewards until all right
it's time to enter the shop okay we're gonna buy a
horizontal one and then oh bad coin implies the modifier to
unmodify coins it touches coupon plus three bars of spin
energy on exchange 20% pie oh I buy this and then I'll gain
plus five plus 15 value while in play plus three percent I'm
getting that and then I'll put this in all right put me in
put me in okay oh Oh, yes.
Oh, and I get a spin, too.
Spin that wheel!
Wait, I've achieved the goal.
I didn't even play the game yet.
I...
You're fucking put that coin in just for fun.
Put him in, too.
Spin that wheel.
I'm ready.
Where's my wheel spin?
Hello?
literally win by not doing spin the wheel
oh my god why aren't you spinning
oh next round oh whoops oh i oh it's next round it's fine
it's fine i didn't realize yeah i was like where's my
fucking wheel you holding out on me you're gonna hold out
all right and that's everything oh oh unless oh it's never
over all right enter shop all right let's buy this and then
we'll get plus two tickets for each coin in selected area
bank oh oh but i'm not keeping my coins i'm i'm putting I'm
throwing it all in.
Whereas coin scored on the specific side.
Resets.
Okay.
Boost plus six value.
Corrupts into.
What's this?
Six to a coin.
And adds plus eight value.
I'm going to grab this one.
I'll grab this just in case.
And then we'll call it here.
All right.
Yes!
Oh shit.
Not the bad apple.
Oh no.
The bad apple.
It's touching my coins.
Okay.
We got the black.
hole now okay this is a little bad oh shit okay auto refill
bad corn is just a little bad I will focus on the left side
so we can grab the oh no it keeps touching it oh there's so
many bad coins okay I'm gonna wait then.
It's giving my coin some bad touches right now.
Not a fan.
Okay, we're going to put this here.
Alright.
We're almost to the... Oh!
Oh, yes!
18, I'll take those.
I'll take 18.
Better nothing.
Okay, it should push it up a little bit then.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Oh, I just need that black hole.
To keep on moving up.
Oh no, my coins are so tiny!
Alright, nice.
He's still pushing.
It's still pushing.
It's still doable.
Alright, we're gonna enter the shop now.
Doubles require combo for spin energy.
Get that shit out of here!
Okay, we're gonna buy the black hole.
I'm gonna buy the shopping coupon too.
One-shaped candle.
When scored.
Uh, ooh, a chummy coin.
I'll buy that, yeah.
Get a little chummy.
Pfft.
A reroll.
Place gadget.
Absorbed coins or every three items sold on exchange.
Plus, and at round start.
Okay, I'm buying that.
this all right let's go all right we got plus eight or keep
spinning okay I all right I'm gonna see if I I do this so I
can suck up the apples does it suck it up yeah get it over
here no that apples still alive no don't touch it don't
Touch my breath!
No!
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's not the taxman.
Like...
I thought it would eat this one too!
Okay, let's see.
We'll grab...
0.5.
Okay, UFO is busted.
Okay, now I know.
Oh, I didn't want him to go down.
All right.
Where's my fucking refund?
Oh, I should have saved the black hole for the turtle.
I should...
I'm so stupid.
I should have saved it.
Okay, I'm gonna...
All right.
Let's get the taxman closer.
Oh, I have another black hole.
Okay, I can do another suck.
Actually, I'm gonna save it the black hole for the turtle
whenever he comes up.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah, yeah, but I'm gonna save it for the turtle.
I think the turtle is more dangerous.
Oh my god, it's still making them tiny.
Oh, come on!
Okay, nice.
I'm- I'm so- where's my refill?
Okay.
Oh Oh We're so close Do I use it?
Should I use the black hole?
If I use the black hole Okay, I'm exchanging
Alright, there we go, we just made it Just give it a little
shake Shake You fool, shake
Alright, there we go.
I almost got rid of the apple too.
I'm just gonna see if I can.
We're almost there.
I might do a suck for here just in case.
If all else fails.
Alright, enter shop.
I think that's the last one.
Gain plus one.
Oh my god.
Why does it keep giving me the bank?
When scored.
Uh...
I'll just buy it for the sake of buying it.
I'll reroll.
Oh, I'll grab that.
Glucoin isn't bad.
Want to play bullish coin.
Okay, wait.
Can I buy more?
Plus 15.
I'll buy...
Oh, just buy an extra one.
I'll buy this.
Oh, never mind.
I can't buy it.
Oh, I'm so stupid.
Why did I...
No!
I was... I didn't read.
Oh, curses.
My lack of readings got me again.
Why do I never read?
Read took...
My lack of readings got me again!
Alright, let's see.
Fuck it.
Just put- get it all in there.
Click first, read later.
The toky special to gamers just don't know how to read.
Okay.
Okay, I just want to get rid of Alright.
Put it all.
You don't want to put it all like Put it all like 56.
Oh, that's a 64 over here.
Yeah, we'll make that 64.
Run dead.
I missed my I missed my old run, guys.
First my tutorial run.
Tutorial Jokey knew what's up.
Where did tutorial Jokey go?
Tutorial Jokey knew how to game.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Might be a little A little fuck, guys.
It's just a little bit.
I think it's time.
We all just suck.
It's the only way.
It's...
Why is it always surprises?
Why?
I don't know.
I don't need the prizes!
I need coins!
Oh no.
Bring Tutorial Doki back.
She knows how to get ball.
She knows how to let it ride.
I missed Tutorial Doki.
Okay.
Oh Oh, nice.
Oh, we did it.
We made it.
We actually made it.
Alright.
An area of effects from prizes.
Plus one coin in the shop.
Can you exchange his lap, but cost... Oh, dear.
He who goes another... I feel like...
Angry Blowfish, right?
Which one do we get, chat?
You guys help me.
I missed tutorial.
I feel like angry blowfish.
Alright, okay, now we...
Oh, now we buy this.
Okay, we should grab that.
Alright, we'll grab this.
And then...
Okay, our slot is full.
Um...
Okay.
What do we get rid of?
I feel like Otter these are good.
Get rid of Fad?
Which one?
This one?
The ticket?
Okay, we'll sell the ticket.
Should we get the cookie redemption or raccoon economics?
Which one's better?
I feel like Cookie Redemption, right?
Or Raccoon.
Oh, they're both.
Or Raccoon Economics.
Economics?
They're both look good.
Oh, Raccoon Economics is crazy good.
All right.
I'm going to...
Should we get rid of another one?
We get rid of Money Bag.
Do we keep Money Bag and then get Cookie Redemption just as
a Hell Mary?
chat i don't know if we should keep money bag or synergize
okay we'll keep that do it all right i'll keep that we'll
start now i'm gonna see if i could get another prize okay
tax man piggy bag
piggy bank seems so good
oh i could start saving okay i'm gonna sell this and buy
piggy bag i could start saving
All right, we'll go with 3% plus 15 by the sticky coin Win
and play per prize score rate
All right, let's go.
I'm ready.
I'm fucking red.
Oh shit.
That's a lot of turtles.
Oh That's a lot of turtles.
Oh and another prize ball who would have thought
Who would have thought?
I'm gonna grab this right now.
Yay!
I don't know if I fucked up there, but...
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Yeah, the AoE was huge.
There.
Okay, we got our roll.
That's good.
Okay, plus 10.
Okay.
All right, that's five.
We just gotta keep going.
Oh, yes.
Yeah, keep that money going, baby.
Oh, my God.
16 combo for one.
Are you kidding me?
Okay.
This is pause.
Combos won't break.
Oh, there's the UFO.
You guys said the UFO is really, really good, right?
all right
okay we're just gonna put put that in that's right oh my god
keep it going let's keep it just throw it all in
okay we save here we save here so now now we have more money
going in then it's all prize balls and yes oh wait we can't
do that all right get rid of this get that in oh this is
gonna be so exciting oh the ufo fell my oh my god i'm so
that's so unlucky
oh my god get that in is that bitcoin yes Fuck it real world
Show me what you got Show me the money
Okay Grab that
Alright I'm ready Just throw it all in
Fuck it Put that in Oh yeah put that Oh and this Oh yeah
Let's just Just throw it all in Okay
All right, come on.
Oh my god, again!
Okay.
Just never stop.
Yeah, we gotta work on the middle, though.
We'll work on the middle.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, he's just flipped.
He did his own little flip.
He's ready to fucking game.
that's for sure oh my god just keep touching each other yes
touch everyone that's why we're all here on this world
okay all right i might have what is that anyway get a prize
after coins scatter from above the upper corner oh my god
it's still there's still there's still so many coins just
touching each other
all right oh nice wait i can exchange it i'm gonna exchange
it so i have 20 coins in hand and i'm gonna enter the shop
nice all right okay now i can
can be silver after six coins insert it at teams plus one
just buy everything uh oh yes let it rain okay when coins
become to conversion rate oh not unused coins really no if i
did i wouldn't have done it okay all right let's go what do
i Oh my god.
Oh, it's still... Okay, that's cool.
I'm cool with that.
Oh my god, that giraffe coin is, like, paying itself off
right now.
Uh...
Fuck it.
Just keep touching it.
Just keep touching.
Yeah, the giraffe coin is so fucking broken.
Let's see it.
Okay, might as well.
Just put everything in.
I don't care anymore.
Put them all in.
Just fucking run.
You know what?
Put those in too!
Just keep on going.
I like it, guys.
Oh my god, I already...
oh my god I have already entered I'm going to put more coins
in my piggy bank too right here alright enter shop oh I
cleared all the bad coins uh autofill has no limit on the
number of you what what's odd oh and prize slots are full
and prize ball is scored send for chance to deploy prize
ball is dropped plus one coin in shop What do we want?
What's dog food?
What does dog food do?
I understand this.
What is the autofill chat?
Dragons, what is really useful?
I don't even know what it does.
Oh, oh,
I see.
Do you want racket or dog food?
Which one's better, dragons?
I don't know.
Which one's better?
Dog food?
I go with food?
Alright, we'll go.
We'll go dog food then.
Alright, what's the bad coin?
Okay, it's still the same one.
Alright, we'll get the...
Buy a taxman, just because we can.
Oh my god, we got to get the bunnies, too.
And then...
Okay, let's go!
Oh, yes!
Keep on going, little guy!
And do your thing!
Oh, my wheel!
Oh, shit, I gotta explode that.
I gotta explode... I gotta explode it.
This is the only way.
Don't worry, surely it'll explode itself.
Oh, no, my giraffe.
No, my giraffe.
Oh, yeah, make sure a giraffe doesn't go in.
Okay.
Oh, I have a lot of coins right now.
Oh, my giraffe.
No!
My beautiful giraffe!
Stay where you are!
I need you to explode!
Okay.
No.
You were boring to keep pushing coins.
You were so beautiful and majestic.
There's 158.
Oh my god.
It keeps...
No, no, right here.
There we go.
Gone but not forgotten, my little giraffe.
Oh, I would never forget your sacrifice.
Explode already!
Why?
Oh, on exchange.
Boom!
Oh, okay, that was anticlimactic.
That...
That's...
That was a little encyclomatic.
Oh my god, another fucking prize ball.
That's it?
That's the boom?
Why is it all prize ball?
All right Okay Oh, this is bad.
I'm not I'm gonna I'm gonna detonate it all Wait, actually,
I could get another prize ball.
There is hope that another prize ball comes into play.
Giraffe, please, one more.
Okay, I'm going to try and destroy this guy real quick.
Okay, nice.
We got all the bad coins out, too.
Nice.
Okay, 25 coins.
We actually really need that.
Okay.
Come on, keep rolling.
Alright, oh no, it's like sort of stuck too.
Okay, I need to like put some over on this side because
there's so many coins on this side right now.
Okay, nice.
Alright, I have to use, that's an exchange coin so I don't
give a fuck about that.
Yeah!
Alright, enter shop.
Uh, plus one chip slot.
Plus one prize slot.
I feel like the prize slot, right?
Chip is this.
Wait.
Chip slot is this, right?
I don't remember which one's Chip slot.
Oh no, Chip slot is the...
Wait, which is better?
Chip slot?
I use prizes more.
Do I need more chips or prize?
I mean, Chip is better?
Wait, it's Chip the...
Chip is the...
Passives, right?
Is Chip's the passive?
Like the side?
It's this side, right?
Okay.
Yeah, we'll grab that then.
They're useful.
We'll grab the tax, man.
I don't like the chummy thing.
Obtain when coins are in hand or less than six.
I'll reroll.
I don't like that.
Oh!
Okay, we need...
We definitely need that.
We do another reroll.
I'll put buy this for now, and then we'll see how it goes.
I don't have to use the bad coins yet.
Oh!
I could do that now.
Okay, let's get the tax man in.
First.
Alright, uh, you know what?
Fuck it.
Put him all in play!
I don't know what I put in play, but they're all in.
They're all in.
I don't know what I put in.
But they're there.
Oh my god, it's another prize ball.
Alright.
Oh my god, I got to shake the cabinet.
I won't get in trouble.
And another one.
Oh, shit.
That's the Jada.
That's right.
Put them all in.
Oh, my God.
They're all just sticking to each other right now.
Let it run.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
This is a little bad because we're not gaining a lot right
now.
Okay.
Okay, 18 coins.
This might save us.
Alright, where is that going to take us?
Nice.
I'm going to put that in.
How much is that anyway?
Mix everything giant.
Okay, but like, what's the value of that?
Oh, shit, 271.
Okay, that's good.
We haven't had any bad coins yet, so it's fine.
Okay, maybe I should...
I'm going to try and get the prize ball on the right side.
Okay, nice.
Okay, come on.
Keep going.
Come on.
I need more coins.
Give me more coins.
Oh, no.
The commo is starting to drop now.
No!
I need it in the keypot going.
That's fine.
Oh, this might be...
Guys, this might be where the run dies.
Okay.
I think I didn't buy the right items.
The combos are slowing down.
Okay, I'm gonna try.
Maybe if I try and shake the counter.
Okay, yeah, maybe the prize will help.
I'm hoping on the prize.
Okay.
I'll put these down and then we'll shake it.
And then we'll start shaking.
All right.
It's time to shake.
I don't think actually I'm exchange again, and then we'll
shake it guys.
We're not making it.
I don't It might be raccoon over I need more coins to be
like at the edge for the shaking to be reliable All right.
Oh, oh, yes All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Okay.
All right, we get rolled out all right we're just only still
halfway come on why is it why is it just prize ball oops all
prize balls what is this oh my god it's a tax man I don't
need more taxes I every tax It's always the fucking tax man
All right, at least we got the auto fill at least Okay, I'm
just gonna focus on the left side
Okay Oh my god, we are at 40 now.
Okay, double the okay.
That's fine.
I'll take those we got another exchange going on okay three
rows come on this keep going keep going oh my god wait wait
there's no way they're gonna give me five prizes after that
there's no fucking way imagine is that did I hear three five
prizes Alright, here we go.
Oh!
Oh my god, stop!
Stop!
I don't want it anymore!
I don't need more bryos
to doki!
And both of them are fucking tax men too.
Oh, this just keeps happening!
Whoops all prizes Oh my god Oh my Please Oh my
This is like my eternal hell This run is so cursed It's like
It's such a fucking cursed run The prize curse is Real I'm
actually stuck in purgatory right now.
I sure do wish I had my prize exploder.
Okay, does the black hole draw?
Oh my god.
Okay, does the black hole draw in like... I'm fucking doing
this.
Oh my god.
This is...
Look at all those prizes.
Look at all of those prizes.
All right, I got the white hole.
All right, let's draw all of those in.
All right.
Surely.
Oh, my!
Stop!
You need more!
Alright, okay.
Alright.
Stop with the prizes!
So, no!
It just... It just...
Alright, it's okay.
We got coins.
It's reading coins.
Prize galores!
Don't get it.
We heard you really love it when we send out more prizes.
Okay.
Wow, we're so close We have another black hole incoming
There is hope Oh my god There might be hope for us Okay
Alright, we made it out of this hellhole We made it out of
the prize hellhole I didn't think it'd be possible Oh my god
Oh my god I didn't think it'd be possible, but we made it
out.
We actually made it out.
Okay, I'm getting rid of the tax man.
Five auto fills trigger this round.
Map coin add.
Okay, we're a grab.
That's crazy that that...
I don't know how that was possible.
Oh my god.
Okay, do we want Balanced Doll or Brain Badge?
Which is better?
Uh...
Why that?
Balanced Doll?
Okay.
Okay, let's see.
I'm buying another of this.
Just as I can.
Okay, we'll get the coordinator.
Alright.
I am...
I'll buy it.
I'll see if I can buy another one.
Buy another coinado.
All right.
I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready.
Let it ride.
All right.
I'm ready.
Oh my god.
Please don't tell me.
Okay.
I didn't get...
All right.
I was gonna say, please don't tell me.
I...
I got it.
It happened again.
I was a little worried that it happened again, but it did
not.
Thank fucking God.
I got so worried.
Okay, we'll grab a sticky coin.
We'll just put all of it in there.
Okay.
What is the most valuable coin in here?
Okay, put that in.
I might as well.
That black hole is coming in anyway.
Alright, nice.
There's still hope for us.
There really is still hope.
There is still hope in this world.
Oh my god!
Stop!
I don't want any more of that.
I'm sorry.
No!
There's no...
Stop!
No, I'm going through hell right now.
I'm going through my own personal hell right now.
What we can do is we start sucking here.
Right here.
Just start sucking.
Yes!
Just yes!
Just suck it all in!
Oh shit, we needed that.
Oh, it's fine.
He's happy.
That's fine.
This is good enough.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
That one's to join in.
Grab the relic.
We could...
Technically we can buy another one.
And we re-roll.
Alright.
We'll buy another killer coin.
And we re-roll.
Just buy it all.
Fuck it.
I have so much money.
Oh, shit.
A white hole.
Alright.
Reworld again.
Okay.
I like the giant modify.
I like that.
Dad!
Hey!
No!
You're going to the dog sitter soon in like 10 minutes.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
Is that the bad coin?
Hunts the most valuable coin.
Oh, you think you got this watch this boom oh shit okay
that's right i'm coming for you get a little closer oh get
out of here damn right
okay but we'll put another glue coin here too and then you
know what have fun get in there just have a ride just go in
fuck you want.
BAM!
I don't know what's going on.
Just do whatever.
Have a party or some shit.
You know what?
Yes!
Just...
Let it rain!
Just keep going!
Keep on going!
It's never ending!
Alright.
Big suck.
Big sucks in the house.
All right, there we go.
Okay, we need to see what the role is now.
I swear the fucking...
How?
How does this keep happening to me?
That's it.
I just said a fucking tornado.
I don't care anymore.
I don't care.
All right, how are we going to get these guys down?
though.
I don't care anymore.
How does this keep happening?
I don't understand.
The world can't have all these prizes.
Oh my god, thank god.
They should eventually run out of prizes, right?
There's no way the prizes are never ending.
There's no...
Like, Joki, there is a way.
There...
Surely, there's an ending to this prize curse.
Surely.
Okay.
Be here.
Alright, I'm gonna let coins drop in.
Oh my god.
Are these coins?
I don't think I've ever seen the day.
Okay.
Coins in my neighborhood?
Say it ain't so.
Alright, nice.
Awesome.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I didn't think that was possible.
Alright.
Alright, just get it all in.
and then make it rain okay we're almost there we're almost
there coins in my prize ball game I thought I'd never see
the day it's a four four please I was like oh thank God okay
okay we're we're five i'm actually i'm actually look i could
actually see a coin in the vicinity okay nice all right okay
oh my god the vacuum cleaner just cleaned it up all right to
be honest i think you need more prizes The dog was just
dropping it into the tornado at this point.
So yeah, what do I do about this tornado?
Oh, it moves towards the scoring zone.
Oh, I don't think my turn is up yet.
I'm still waiting.
Oh my god, we achieved the goal.
actually possible, guys.
It's...
Oh my God, it's still going on.
Okay, I think that's it.
Alright, we got...
You clear the bad coins.
Choose a keychain.
Alright.
Black card plus one exchange limit gains three more in hand.
Coin.
Increase chance of buy one, get one.
When you get a prize, 40% chance to spawn a prize ball at
the same I could get more prizes.
I think what we've been wanting more of to do with more
pride.
You're so right, guys.
You're so fucking right.
I think that's what we were lacking this entire time.
More fucking prizes.
Like, apparently you guys said the UFO is really, really
good uh oh plus two for three round chocolate coin i'll buy
this i'll reroll and then we'll grab that glue red pocket uh
uh what is the bad coin instead of being scored coins are
destroyed wow okay we gotta get rid of that uh get rid of
this and we'll reroll oh another killer coin
Okay.
Uh.
I think I'll reroll again, see I can get any more.
Alright, we're good to go.
Alright, put UFO down right away.
Alright, how do I...
What do I do with UFO?
How does this work?
Uh...
I don't know how this works.
I put it down.
All right, I hope I didn't fuck it up I don't know how this
is how it's working
Oh shit hey
Oh, it's not that important.
That's good to know because I just legit didn't know what to
do
Oh shit.
Oh Okay, I get it now.
I see
All right, I see you now.
Okay, just in case the fucking prize ball starts showing up.
Let me start sucking this up.
Just...
Just in case.
Oh, I fucking called it.
All right.
Oh, my God.
I fucking knew.
I fucking...
I knew I knew that was going to happen to me.
Just start shaking.
Just...
I fucking just...
Just start...
Putting everything down.
I fucking knew I fucking knew you were gonna do that
bullshit on me.
I I knew I had to start shaking.
Oh, question mark.
Oh, I got a second wheel.
Sell the prizes.
Oh, I'm tower stacking.
Oh, there it goes.
I'm stacking that tower.
Wait, what do I just...
Alright.
There goes the tower.
And there it goes.
Oh, tower's gone.
Sir, I've destroyed the tower.
Alright.
Oh, I just need to keep selling.
The leaning tower.
a prize all right oh but I'm gonna shake this and if I get
any prize I will sell it wait I could actually no I'll do it
now sell it now and then I'll call him in oh my god oh my
god he's got my UFO he's got he's got my UFO my UFO did not
know what to do my UFO UFOs started freaking the fuck out!
Oh my god.
My UFO was so confused.
The counter got countered.
Okay.
UFOs does that.
You know what?
Let's just...
There we go.
There.
There we fucking go.
I swear, if I hit another prize thing, I'm ready for it.
I'm fucking ready.
Alright, nice.
Okay, this has been the calmest.
I will say, it has been very, surprisingly, very calm now.
Surprisingly, the calmest has ever been.
Alright.
All right, we're gonna put some coins in.
I might have to run the black hole, right?
Run it here.
Just so I can have potential to have more stuff come in.
All right, nice.
This is it.
At any moment in time, this is the one time, one time that I
won all the prizes.
This is that moment.
Yeah.
Right here is that one moment I needed to be all prizes.
Oh my god.
Okay, whatever.
The one time I have the Bakugan badge, it decides to not
give me prizes.
The only time I've ever asked for anything in life.
They ran out, Toki.
There's too many prizes.
The only time I needed this in my life When I have the
perfect prize to activate it Oh my god, this is it Alright,
oh my god These ones suck, but it's Ah, whatever I'd rather
just sell it so I can grab a UFO Fuck it Okay Oh wait, okay,
well All right.
All right.
It's time.
Activate.
Oh, my God.
I thought it would, when it said activate, I, okay, never
mind.
I thought it would activate three black holes.
I didn't realize it just combusts.
That's my bad.
Well, now I know.
It just combusts.
I thought it would...
I should have sold it.
Who would have known?
I thought detonate as in, like, I'm going to open the
capsule.
I thought that's what it meant.
I thought they were going to open the capsule for me.
I thought it would explode.
like exploding as in like oh i'm gonna activate it oh no i
think our run is dead here guys our run might be over okay
this might be where we this might be where we have the 07
the run
all right that's fine we've had a good run
Oh, now you don't want to give me any prizes.
Yo, okay.
La-di-da.
Oh, I see.
This is now you don't want it.
Alright.
I'm just gonna put it all on the right side.
Oh, eight coins.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I need more than that.
I have to get a 300.
thousand dollars or they're gonna get me or the dead police
they're gonna get me
okay oh this is so bad
oh i should have sold if i knew i would have sold it i would
have had two black holes I...
It was the two big black holes!
Oh, we're in trouble now.
We're sort of in trouble now.
Oh, the bird came in.
Someone fed the dog.
Okay.
At least someone fed the dog.
okay maybe
oh we don't have enough we're not even halfway oh if only i
didn't explode the prizes why did no one stop me
okay oh this is so bad oh this is so bad oh oh my god Is
that?
Oh, that's a white hole.
Okay, there is hope.
Oh, in those 10 coins.
In those 10 coins.
Oh, I have 10 coins left.
Okay.
Oh, it's not getting closer.
Oh, and I fucked it up.
Oh, why?
I need coins.
Oh.
us why oh my god no now it's pushing the prize
wait wait i'll sell this oh the ufo the ufo okay wait wait i
sold a prize okay i sold that okay all right please please
36 okay there's hope there's hope so out you one good okay
we're desperate now we're selling the money off of our backs
all right we gotta sell the raccoon paw what no i'm closing
the door oh my god no wait no one time We can shake.
We can shake it.
I can sell this too.
I can.
Oh my god.
No.
There's still hope.
Keep believing.
Please.
I just need black hole.
I need any hole.
Oh my god.
Yes!
Okay.
wait oh my god where are all the coins congregating right
now right here right here okay all right all right all right
we there's still hope there's still hope we there's still
hope that you know my UFO oh my god and there's 30 coins the
run's not dead yet There's more coins coming in.
Come on.
Yes.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
It's just halfway there.
No.
It's okay.
Don't.
It's still only halfway.
It's all right.
Come on.
Keep going.
Oh, God, I can't even do anything with the prizes.
I...
Okay, wait, it's still, it's still pushing.
Guys, it's still pushing.
Okay.
All right, we got the coins.
The coins are still pushing it.
All right.
Come on.
Yes!
All right.
We gotta sell this.
Okay.
All right.
We have 18 more coins.
No, it's okay.
We don't use it yet.
We have three holes.
Yes.
Come on.
Use.
All right.
And then we use that right here.
Right now.
all right so we don't waste that all right good we're still
alive we're somehow still alive okay okay okay it's fine
it's okay it's okay we're still alive
still it's still there it's still there all right there's a
ufo's cabin
okay here we go here we go darn right we're still we're
still in it here okay that's
cool We'll keep going.
I don't know.
It's still going live.
And that's all that matters.
Oh my god.
I swear to you.
Okay.
Second wheel.
What is...
Oh my god.
I don't know if I...
I have a tower.
How am I going to get this tower over here?
Okay.
The never-ending run.
I'm so kidding.
Now we have a tower.
Okay.
Alright.
I can't see the monitor anymore, apparently.
I don't.
No.
Yeah, but the combo is still going, though.
I'll still, I'll sell it when I need it, when I'm desperate.
Not yet.
We're not desperate yet.
It's still going.
The run has not stopped for some reason.
My one move is still going on.
My one move has not ended.
I take those.
We're doing another run now.
Oh, there we go.
I've been alive for so long.
I'm hanging by a thread right now.
The coin tower is getting closer.
all right i'll activate it when i'm desperate this is an
idle game this has been like my yugioh turn i've been alive
for 20 turns
all right here we go i think it stops here i think it's time
to summon the ufo is it over over Am I am I allowed to make
a move yet?
All right, now I drop all right here we go Here we go.
Oh, it's so moving All right UFO.
Oh my god.
I'm
And I live Okay, this is it Well, I'm alive.
I...
I made it.
I don't know.
I guess I made it.
All right.
Well, then.
I survived.
um i don't even know what to buy anymore i don't even know
plus for coins and play but minus 10 per after torque target
score has been reached okay we're gonna buy a black hole uh
holy freedom
Fuck it Just keep buying 40% chance to apply Golden or
triangle to What do we get this?
Wait, clip is empty Oh wait, no We'll grab this And then
Grab that
I don't know if I like these Each conversion plus two buy
angry dog well i don't know where angry dog is
oh i should have bought it okay well now i know maybe angry
dog will come back maybe guys maybe it'll come back you
don't know that it'll come back guys
okay Grab that.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I'm going to sell that.
I'm going to buy this.
What the fuck?
Are any of these good or nah?
I'll buy this.
Oh, hey.
There he is.
Buy another one of that.
Maybe angry police dog.
Keep re-rolling until angry dog comes back where's my angry
dog where are you silver paint immune effects that destroy
coins angry dog we need you come back oh shit I didn't even
realize my I don't I can't reroll anymore oh
shit The angry dog did not come back.
No!
What do we get?
Bird or pocket watch?
Oh, no.
Square?
Oh, wait.
Oh, these doxers here.
Okay.
I'm heading down now.
Oh, shit.
Alright, we're gonna do this Go play Play this Pour that
shit in Oh shit, that's not what I wanted That's why, oh
darn it Fuck it Just gonna shake it Might as well since
we're here And then No black hole right away Alright, I'm
gonna Maybe they'll start play I'm gonna The game's gonna
start playing itself.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna go get dad to the dog today.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Did my...
Did my game had fun time playing for itself?
Oh, it's still going.
It's...
Alright.
Well, I hope my game had a fun time playing, too.
I hope they had a good time.
I got more.
What is that?
Wow, I got more prizes.
Who's surprised?
Get it?
Oh my God.
Are we all surprised there?
All right.
Oh my God.
Fuck it.
Oh wow.
Here we go again.
Here we fucking go again.
Alright, let's black hold of this.
I'm desperate.
Fuck it.
Just...
Is that more prizes?
Wow!
Oh my god.
All right, 40 coins.
Might as well sell the tax man.
And then...
You know what?
Send the saw in.
Fuck it.
Just send that guy in.
The coins.
When do they stop?
Just send him in.
Let him have fun.
Let it rise.
Let them have fun.
Oh, shit.
I don't remember what it's like to put place coins down.
I forgot what that's like.
I haven't placed the coin down in 20 years.
Okay.
I missed the giraffe coin.
Bring back the giraffe coin.
Bring him back.
tell him we miss him tell him we still think about him to
even to this day oh
my god I I mean okay I okay yeah giraffe coin was the
fucking goat guys he knew how to party I don't know if this
is the right Unless I have a 20-minute turn.
I don't know.
We gotta rely on having a 20-minute turn.
All right.
More coins.
Okay.
Here we go.
It's not another turn.
Just give it a few more hours.
Yeah.
Okay, I got the second wheel.
Oh, wow!
It's okay, I'm getting a UFO right here.
Wow!
Is that...
Did I see what I just saw?
Oh, thank God.
We're actually stacking a tower this time.
Oh, thank fucking God.
I thought I'd never see the day.
My title.
I thought I would never see the day.
It's finally happening.
You know what?
Just in case.
I'm not just in case.
Where's my feet?
Get back in here!
Oh, yay!
all right here we go again here we go yeah oh my god an a
coin more don't you they read how much you love it they were
stocked on it just for you
We're gonna have to suck here.
And then hope to God.
We're gonna hope to God.
Like we can make something out of this.
But right here.
Stop.
Please.
I can't keep doing this to me.
Oh my god.
There must be other ways.
There we go.
Alright.
That's fine.
This is fine.
Every single time.
It would be pretty neat though.
You know, we had like, I don't know.
Like a thousand coins into the would be pretty cool.
We had a thousand coins.
Okay, it's fine.
Okay, here we go.
I don't think I threw a coin in in a long time, I will say.
I don't remember what it was like to throw coins in.
I don't remember.
Selling
Oh, fuck, it just...
I don't know what's going on anymore.
Alright.
Oh, my god.
Alright, it's okay.
I don't think I've ever seen coins before in my life.
There actually is what's keeping me alive.
Oh, my god, you got the prize.
Is that just...
I've accepted my fate.
It's just what I was born to do.
Just suck it all up.
Put it back all the way up top.
Put it back up.
Okay, tax doll, black hole, fish.
Okay, we don't need any of those.
I'm feeling so many multipliers.
I don't think I've had a move yet.
I don't think I've done a single move yet.
I've just been rolling prizes.
Oh my god.
I don't...
How am I getting...
Oh my god.
How am I gaining coins?
How...
Alright, another black hole.
It's just all silver coins
I think this is turn three I This is this is turn number
three by the way
Way through All right
At this rate, I'm surprised at the I'm used I'm surprised at
the lack of prizes I think it's finally happened The game
has stopped giving me prizes.
Dokey, are you playing an idle game right now?
Are you-
Coin in my rack coin game?
I want a fucking refund, Dokey.
Um.
I was promised prizes.
What the fuck is this?
Yeah, what if I fucking gotcha?
Of course.
All right, we did it.
Oh my god, turn number three.
I have 126 coins in my hand.
How does it keep going up?
Christ, everywhere.
Can't you see them?
Simple.
Thank you for this super chat.
Thank you, Dave.
The goal is to put coins.
It's to put coins in the machine.
But I don't remember what that was like.
I haven't done that in a while.
I will say.
I'm at the speed run.
I'm at the start.
I'm gonna...
I'm just gonna fast forward now.
Is this what passive income is like?
Oh, there it is.
There...
I haven't seen you in a while, little buddy.
So...
I think this is still turn three.
I think.
All right.
Good.
Okay.
Are we done now?
Can I still use my third turn?
All right.
Turn number three.
all right
oh no yeah it's a cookie clicker wait I think I made it oh
my god not a prize is so rare yay yay all right we've made
it to turn three.
Well, I'm gonna buy the black hole.
Um, well, I guess we refill our coin.
We already have killer coin.
And then...
We'll buy this so we can sell it later.
I don't know how I made it here.
I...
Do we keep the square pocket?
We should get the angry, right?
Okay.
Oh my god, giraffe, my beloved!
Should we sell square, right?
And then should we get silver paint for now?
Oh my god, giraffe, my beloved.
I never forget you.
Should we get...
silver paint or no or should we reroll guys dragons it's
back to serve me once
more all right we'll grab so I'll reroll just to see if we
get anything better
around pocket watch we
want are any of these better or no dragons are
any No?
I re-roll.
Air token, raccoon poster.
I have more red pocket.
I'm gonna
sell this and buy that.
Um.
Are any of these better or nah?
Nah, I'm re-roll.
None of these seem like really good right now.
I'll do...
I'm gonna sell this and buy this.
I'll do one more re-roll.
Alright, do it.
Alright, is this better or not?
I'll do one more.
Alright.
And then these are better.
No more re-rolls.
Actually, I can do another re-roll.
Oh, Silver Bean was good.
Maybe he'll come back!
I didn't know!
I don't read properly, you know this!
Where's landlord?
I'm so bad at reading!
You know this!
I might buy this.
Alright, whatever.
We're gonna go here.
Oh, shit.
When did he...
Oh, alright.
Go do your thing, I guess.
Um.
I'm gonna sell this too.
I...
Go have fun.
I'll take it.
Go cut some shit too.
I don't care.
750?
I'm still on my first run.
I mean, alright.
Oh, what is that?
Oh, is that another prize?
Oh, you shouldn't have.
Oh, you really shouldn't have.
Alright, well.
well you know the drill there we go start sucking I guess
all right do your thing
all right we'll
put one of that here I'll put you here put you here and you
here And then...
It's time to suck.
Alright, slowly push these guys over.
I need to push these guys over.
Oh, I should sell.
Yeah, I'll sell that.
Alright.
This is turn one, technically.
It's still turn one.
I haven't...
Still 10...
I have 120.
24 coins.
Oh.
I need these two so I can steal them.
Come on.
Keep pushing them.
There's turns.
Oh, nice.
I mean, sure.
More stuff to steal, I guess.
Okay.
Can I throw a coin in now?
Am I allowed to?
to?
All right.
I'm on turn.
Oh.
Whoops.
A little bit too.
I also got a little too excited there.
I didn't have to put a coin in.
It was still in play.
All right.
Now.
Now I can put a coin in.
I got a little too excited, apparently.
All right.
Nice.
I need to get like a good.
All right.
Yeah, I can sell this one.
Yeah, and you know, grab that other one so I can keep
selling it.
Alright, second wheel tab.
Oh, I got 42 stacker.
Oh, that's it in 42?
I thought I'd get more, honestly.
Oh, shit.
Okay, goodbye.
The tower has been sucked.
I repeat.
All right, nice.
I don't know why I want to run.
I'm not going to run the black hole yet.
And then get other coins in place first.
Okay, nice.
I don't think I'm going to lose coins anytime soon.
It's a never-ending loop of rebuilding my currency.
I was like, Oh, okay, I still have 133.
Oh my god, I finally got under 130 now.
Oh, I got my money back.
I...
Okay.
I think it's time for the black hole.
Put more in the center.
All right, I think it's time.
All right, nice.
Send in the cavalry.
Oh, hey, that's...
Alright.
I'm not complaining.
I...
I mean, it's fine.
It's what we wanted to see, you know?
Fuck it.
Hey, what did you do right side?
I didn't grab these prizes, though.
Alright, we got tax dollars.
I'm gonna grab I'm gonna focus on the left so I can get that
guy what that guy right over here
I need that guy to start moving same with oh my god it auto
filled why why did it auto fill our second wheel oh yeah I
oh eight coins all right
I have a lot of coins to sell I'm just trying to get that
black hole if I get that black hole these three over there
all right and then we can suck this and that's gonna push
these guys see and I can sell that and then from that it'll
start the chain again and from that I basically got all my
money back I still don't understand how I'm getting my money
back but I won't complain oh look at that Wow look at more
I'm gonna get my I've I got my money back it's like I never
stopped spending
all right and then we can do it again right here and then
sell sell all of these back in there and all right the UFOs
coming in too
Oh wow, did I hear another refill?
Okay, all right.
Well, I can do this again.
And then I guess, whoa, whoa, stop, chill.
Calm down, calm down, everyone.
Okay,
I'm still on my first run, by the way.
I...
We have yet to lose this run.
I'm on, I don't even know what turn I'm at.
I literally, I made money somehow.
I somehow started with more money than where I started.
I don't know where all this money came from.
Okay.
All right, are we allowed to calm down now?
I don't think I've seen a bad coin in 20 years, honestly.
It's been a while since I've seen one.
I made this an idle game, not gonna lie.
I really did accidentally made this an idle game.
All right, here we go.
Can I do another black hole now?
Oh, where did this guy come from?
Okay, I got another black hole.
I forgot I can duplicate that.
I was like, where did he come from?
Where did he come from?
All right, so I have another black hole.
from the sky, I guess.
Oh my guys, I'm finally, okay.
I'm finally stacking again.
I thought I would never see the day.
Yeah, I forgot I had that.
Alright, here we go.
Auto-fill.
Oh, another auto-fill.
Oh, we're auto-filling again.
What?
I don't even...
Okay.
I thought I would never see a tower.
Oh, and the tower's gone.
And the tower's gone.
It's already gone.
I saw it and it left.
Okay.
I did.
Alright.
Are we okay?
Are we...
Can I make a move now?
Can I...
Oh, alright.
Send that in.
Might as well.
All right.
One last move.
This is the last.
Oh, I did it.
I won.
All right.
I mean, sure.
I'll sell this just.
Oh, I forgot about.
Well, just have fun there.
Oh, all right.
I won't.
It's just first try.
It did it.
That was a tough one.
Natural first try
Yay!
It was a long intense journey I've unlocked so many things I
don't even think this game expected this
The game had to force me to stop Oh my god Very cool.
Yay!
I mean, we could, honestly...
We can still keep going.
Uh...
We could get more.
I mean, technically...
I could get more.
I could actually get more.
Wait, do I...
When I sell it...
Alright, let's just...
Let's just keep going, I guess.
Oh, powers UFO?
Why don't you just...
Fuck it.
Let's keep buying.
Oh, that's so good.
But I have so many.
No, I'm keeping the silver coin.
That shit's clutch.
No, I have so many tickets.
I don't even know what I'm doing right now.
I'm just slowly powering everything up.
Alright.
Oh, another giraffe coin.
Fuck it.
Get that rice cooker.
What the fuck is this?
Oh, shit.
Wait, I'll buy that.
We don't even need that.
Not gonna lie.
Fuck it.
Oh, my God.
And I get another one.
I'm just powering it all.
I'm...
I'm just Fuck it I don't know how much I've stocked up on
this But let's, we're keep, we're gonna keep on going
That UFO is gonna go Fucking crazy Oh,
is that max already?
Oh, whoops, alright, let's go I don't know, I just thought I
thought it was like I thought it like stacks up oh yeah no
it's still going on six million i just thought it was
stacking up i was just having a field day i was just letting
it have a party you know party at the ufo
yeah that's a little bit of a jump not gonna lie i didn't
expect six million that's a little a lot going in yeah
endless doesn't fuck around endless truly is endless
all right here we go hip potty rock is in the house tonight
but i know no no no no no no
All right, here we go.
Still going.
Nice.
Still pushing.
Who I like to see.
Yeah, I can start.
I'm going to start UF.
I'm going to start white-holding this, too.
So I can grab the auto-refill.
I'm going to come back in.
Come on, you know, Yawana.
I'm going to have to start.
Draft down.
Draft's gotta start partying now.
Slow and steady, guys.
We are getting to a little loop.
Guys.
The prize loop.
We gotta pray for the prize loop, guys.
The moment the prize loop hit.
Okay.
All right, that is.
Slowly but surely.
The loop of the prize.
Brick by brick.
Oh, it's shy.
It's a little shy, guys.
The prizes are a little shy.
They didn't realize it was going to go endless.
They thought it was...
I thought it was over, too.
I...
They're like, wait, we're still going.
They're like, guys, wait, I really need a reason.
They sent a guy out to buy some more prizes.
Alright.
Oh, there you go.
It's starting.
What the fuck is this?
Coin, it gained value.
Okay, we don't need more.
We don't need more tickets, honestly.
They're like, They had to go down to like Costco To refill
Give it a sec guys They gotta do a Costco run
I'm gonna try Push the prize ball down I'm gonna start
selling that
Okay Oh my god I forgot what it was like to use coins This
is like A new experience for me.
I have to use my own coins in the coin pusher game.
What the fuck is this?
Technically, I'll sell this.
I'll put this down.
What the fuck happened?
Oh, shit.
Goodbye.
Okay.
Oh, another one.
Another prize, Bob, in looking for you.
Yeah, I need to put that down.
Come on, we're so close.
Yes!
It's almost there!
Yeah!
All right, now I can tell you.
Yeah, make it rain, UFO!
Make it rain!
All right.
Nice.
We made it rain.
That's why I love you.
like to see.
Guys, I think Endless, I don't, I think we might.
This might be it, we're...
Guys, we might, we might actually see an end to Endless.
You've done it, Lou.
Hey, Jokey's my birthday today.
I want to keep supporting and really enjoy the time.
Watching, oh, oh, and that's how it starts.
That's...
That's how we start
Jesus Six million How the fuck Happy birthday though Yavi
Thank you, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday to you Happy birthday
dear Yavi Happy birthday to you Yay!
I got a great birthday!
You're just watching me.
Very silly.
Stop pushing.
More coins!
Shake it off!
All right.
Someone said more coins!
Oh!
All right.
We're just going to grab these prizes out.
Okay.
This should send the UFO out now.
Alright, nice.
Got the UFO in.
Starting eating.
Yum, yum, yum.
Where's my auto filler?
Auto filler!
Ring, ring!
Hello!
Do your job, bird!
Where the fuck's the bird?
The auto fill, where?
Where?
Start shaking.
Oh my god, I got another one.
Nice.
Oh, there you are.
Oh my god.
Sleeping on the job, I see.
That lazy bro.
You thought you could sleep on the goddamn job?
I just haven't seen a fucking black hole yet.
Okay.
We're gonna sell that.
So I can get another shaker down there.
and we need a shaker no sleep only coins oh my god I'm
starting to see the end of the I'm starting to see my coins
actually dwindling down we're not even at a million yet
we're out we didn't get our loop why did it make me stop my
loop the loop potential was endless it really was We had
endless potential!
Alright, we need to try and see if we can get the dog shake.
Oh, okay, well, I mean, what the fuck is that?
Alright, we gotta sell that.
I'm gonna shake it.
There we go.
Nice, the auto fills going in now.
Nice, that's what we need it.
nice oh yep all right you know that's that's what we needed
that's exactly what we need okay
I need the mask of the same rarity what can I do for that oh
my god what do I just convert it all the drafts
I mean, they're all giraffe coins.
If I get to a million, I call that a win.
If I can get to a million coins.
Alright, a million tickets.
Oh, shit, nice.
Alright.
Should I put a killer coin in?
Wait, can I convert all my coins?
Is my killer coins...
Extremely expensive.
Oh, hey, look at that.
It's what I needed.
And that's it's what I needed, guys.
All right, put this here.
Can I try to do it now?
I'm gonna do it.
Oh, shit.
What the?
Oh my god, what?
What happened?
Shit.
Oh my god.
Wait, what happened?
What are all these coins?
Oh my god, because they're really exploded right now.
The power of the earth.
How did I just hit a million?
Right off the bat.
Alright.
I'll take it.
those okay oh shit all right yeah refilled oh yeah another
prize yay oh shit oh everything's falling okay so that UFO
is coming in clutch You should get into that loop cycle.
Oh, nice.
Sell it.
Salad, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Oh, shit.
Okay, come on.
Yes!
All right.
Okay, let's let me...
It works.
I mean, sure.
Sure.
We'll keep going with the prizes.
That's fine.
Okay, we're gonna have to...
Okay, we're gonna try and push these guys down, though.
Like, sure.
Okay, it works, guys.
Okay, I actually need this guy to go down, though.
All right, we actually...
That's good.
We got the refill.
We can sell that.
All right, here we go again.
Oh, oh, black hole!
Nice!
Okay, all right, that's actually really good for us.
All right, so now I can do this.
And then, oh, I got another rat.
All right, okay, that's, all right.
And then UFOs coming in too.
The UFOs here.
All right, eight coins.
Okay.
I do need to get the...
this guy down, though.
So I can sell it.
Oh, I refilled my money.
Okay.
I'll take those.
We're looping it!
Back to the loop!
It's like we never left!
And I'll do that.
And I sell that.
Okay.
It's like the loop never left.
I told you it takes a while.
It takes a while to get the loop.
going.
Oh my god, now I'm profiting.
Run the loop.
They got the match and restock the prizes, guys.
Oh, okay.
320 more!
Holy shit.
Oh my
god, how do you even still have autumn fill up?
on that's a lot of coins oh my god oh it's coming towards me
i'm scared oh hey i mean all right i might be able to grab
prize over there i guess
you know what send that prize down here so i can grab that
ufo in oh i'm ready for that UFO to come in.
Alright, here we go.
I can't.
Hey, 2 million.
Alright.
Oh, we did it.
I told you guys.
Y'all wait for the loot.
I'm surprised this is still the first run.
It's like Velocity Allo.
again i don't know how i keep doing this every every
roguelike i just do i just complete the game in the first
run it just keeps happening oh all right we got the loop
again gambling is bad guys right so what did we learn guys
so what did we learn today everybody
This keeps happening.
Alright, UFOs here.
I mean, alright.
Oh, there they go.
There they go.
Oh, there's another one.
Oh, I got another mast doll.
Let's go.
Let's...
I mean, chair.
Chair.
I'll sell that.
Where's my- I just need to wait for my refill.
Oh, it's shit nice.
My coin stacker.
Here he comes.
I got my refill.
What if I mask on the town?
Yeah, I was thinking that.
Whoa!
Wow!
What?
So it does work.
So if anyone is curious, you can indeed mask the tower.
Oh my god.
In one mask, I reached 3 points.
I'm at 4 million.
I think I gained up 2 million dollars in one mask.
well then what I blinked what happened to I honestly
I don't know you guys want to see it again
oh my god I got another mask oh god I got oh where did these
guys come from oh they want to they want to have sex so
badly The target is too low.
They should have made it higher.
You're so right.
I mean, sure.
I mean, you know what?
Like, fuck it.
Alright.
90.
That one ramped up real.
It was, it took a while, guys.
It got a little slow.
slow at first.
At first, it took you so awesome how lucky you're all the
time.
You aspire to try my luck at my local slot.
To try to double my rent.
Wish me luck at both the last of... Hey, maybe it can work
for me.
Oh, I did it.
I...
What happened?
I looked away to read my super chat.
Wait.
I I looked away to read my super chat and it was over.
That's crazy.
I don't even know what happened.
One more mask for the road.
I actually don't know what happened.
I'm just reading my super chat.
All right.
buy a relic and then we'll exchange it and then okay we do
need another killer coin though just like a precaution the
loop continues
can we max it out already i can't tell
all right see we can grab another bad
what's this let's go i there's i let's just go in let's just
go in i'll have another two prizes
what's the target it's there's not even a number anymore
the numbers stopped existing i don't even think we have a
number anymore guys
All right, here we go.
Does that even...
Yes.
We have letters in our numbers.
That's how far we're at.
I see our closer...
Wait, we're almost there.
What happened?
What the fuck happened?
I don't even know what happened.
We're almost there.
I literally just blinked.
I mean, I'll take it.
Hey.
Oh, shit.
Another prize.
Yippee.
When did they start adding the LP?
fit into the into the numbers i don't even know what
happened guys i'm just trying to try and push this guy over
what the fuck
how did my ball of prize go there oh another one sweet
all right
i could use it to clear it i should save it for the next one
i'm not gonna waste it now
oh nice yeah make it rain yeah
oh my god is that another prize let's go
oh Hey, maybe I'll get another mask.
You don't know that, guys.
I could get another mask right here.
It could happen.
Right here.
Right now.
Okay, I got another hole right.
Oh, still going.
Alright, nice.
Oh, I got another one!
Another white hole!
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Is this...
Another black horse?
Oh my god.
Alright.
I mean, I'll take it.
I think we broke the economy.
It just never ends.
I'm surprised we actually...
I'm surprised that like...
The what?
The coin stopped.
Surprise!
It stopped!
Help, here we go.
We're just fucking...
Let's just go right into it.
You know, just have fun.
Just have a good time.
Just have fun.
And just put more UFOs in there too.
See where that leads me.
No, this is still my first run.
I have...
I haven't seen this increased yet, which is what worries me.
I'm glad that, like, the mask gave me a huge clutch there.
Because I haven't seen the 7 part go up to an 8 yet.
I don't even, I don't know where we're at.
The mask did so much.
It really did.
for another mask at this point to see where it takes me all
right here we go oh i got another spin though by 40 coins
okay at least the white hole comes back at least at least it
comes back
cycle of red holes.
Alright, here's another backstop.
Come back to get sold again.
Oh, there we go.
Come back again to get sold, I guess.
You gonna come back?
Oh, there you go.
He's back.
He's coming.
Yeah, 320.
320.
His purpose is to get sold and re-sold again.
Oh, there he...
Hey, welcome back there!
So I can do this again.
Oh, there he comes.
I didn't lose my white hole yet.
Alright, he's finally left.
The tax man has finally left.
The mask leaves.
The mask comes back.
all right
i'm honestly just waiting for another mask at this point oh
my god it finally changed the numbers are different now i've
never seen the day
it went from 3.7 to 3.8 guys it finally happened what is the
numbers change Okay, pause, screw badge, rich, okay, I don't
need any of these, which means I can do another white hole
and just let it keep going.
And which means I can do a black hole here and then have
more stuff keep going.
And I'll sell that and then I can sell that too.
all right that's good let's keep the cycle up i have 400
coins i we can play with that i i'm it's literally
impossible for me to go broke at this point i don't think
it's possible for me to run out of money all
right okay
100 coins We just need a really, really big tower so I can
mass doll it.
That's all we need.
Bring us the tower.
Alright.
Oh my god.
They don't want me to have the tower.
They don't want to make the game too easy for me.
They're like, they're cute.
This game is too easy now.
We're gonna fuck my refill.
Yeah, the loop is on cooldown at the moment, guys.
Yeah, wait a little bit.
Yeah, wait for the loop.
Alright.
25.
Oh, you're so close to the tower, though.
It's literally right there.
I haven't seen the raccoon in so long like not raccoon I
haven't seen the giraffe coin in so long my family have been
wondering where I am
my family has been waiting for me they don't know when my
son is already in university
the graduations.
God for cigarettes.
I missed our 80th anniversary.
And more prizes.
Oh, hey, more prizes.
I just need the tower.
Give me the tower.
Literally, that's all we're missing.
Oh my god.
We're just missing the fucking tower.
Please!
One tower to end it all!
To end this!
It.
It's right here.
That's all we need.
Alright, come on.
Come on.
Daddy needs a new tower!
Oh!
No!
Oh, we got a mass dollar a little bit.
Fuck it.
We got a...
It's okay.
We got a mass dollar of this, at least.
The little things, guys.
Oh no.
I got...
Come on.
Yes!
Come on!
It's alright, it's over.
It's over.
We got what we need.
We got what we needed.
And we got another masked up.
Oh my god.
Oh my.
I...
Where is everything all so okay?
Okay.
It's happening.
Yes.
All right, we didn't need to be fair.
I could do, you guys want to see something funny?
Wait, give me a sec.
All right, I could technically end this right now.
Oh, okay, wait, not yet.
All right, we jumped up three.
a six oh
my god made my money back i need a hundred coins from that
load like please just stack
oh my god oh here refill tab
all right i just need to wait for it to stop it hasn't
stopped yet i'm i just i'm waiting for it okay here we go
right here okay actually no it has to fill up a little bit
more all right right here there we go well there it goes
there i'm 32 as well oh shit nice let's go all right we
literally just need all of these coins to start dropping
down and we be good.
Okay, I need...
Okay, I need to grab this.
I can get the UFO in.
Alright, nice.
Okay, now I have a UFO.
Right here.
And then the refill tab.
And then...
Oh, come on!
Give me the tower!
I feel like at this point the only way I can stop a run is
if I stop myself like I have to end in myself oh my god only
84 I'll take it pretty much like I'm not allowed to stop
this like the game won't let me end it I don't see an ending
I think it's sad I think it's time to go my god
There's no way it's gonna end It's never gonna end The game
won't let me It's not gonna let me end Guys
okay it will end soon oh my god $23,000 like what am I gonna
what am I gonna do what oh bad coin oh no what am I gonna do
about the bad coin oh no
oh What am I gonna do?
Oh, I'm so scared.
I'm so scared about a bad court.
Oh, no.
What am I gonna do?
Oh, my God!
I mean...
It's gone.
Wait.
I'm already there.
What
happened?
What?
It's gone.
I made it to...
Wait, you're almost there, Toki.
You're here.
Just like that.
Oh no.
What am I gonna do, guys?
You're 10% of the way.
Don't worry, guys.
All we need is a really good loop.
That's all we need.
We just need one mask.
when it's over.
I might still...
This is still my first run.
I don't know.
I've been on my first run for a while now.
Oh.
Here's the tower.
I mean, to be fair, I feel like we just pushed this tower
down right now.
Ha ha ha ha.
Like, we can literally just do that now.
Just put some coins down there.
It'll eventually start going down.
Yeah.
A mask will eventually start coming in.
I believe.
I believe in the power of the mask.
Ha ha ha.
Oh, this tower is stuck, stuck right now.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I know the mask would go so hard right now.
It would.
It honestly would.
I'm slowly pushing this so I can start selling more of the
prize.
Okay.
I'm actually using coins now it's okay the loop is on
cooldown the loop is on cooldown right now we're just on a
cool down Jesus Christ all right here we go
We're almost to the cooldown loop.
It's okay.
More prizes.
Eventually, UFOs can come suck that up, honestly.
Alright, another one.
It's not gonna fall for now, only because it's a very big
tower.
There's a lot in there.
But it's okay.
We have, we have prize.
We have plenty of prizes.
We have plenty of prizes to go around.
Oh, there we go.
There it goes.
Oh.
Truly, it'll give me, okay, I got black hole right here.
And down it goes.
We just need to grab that.
Blackle.
Okay.
Alright, technically all of these can be sold.
Alright, here we go.
We're playing the long...
Oh my gosh, okay.
We're playing the long game here, guys.
I'm gonna put...
Oh.
Put this in, so that I can sell this and I can sell this,
too.
I can sell this.
All right, so need to.
The long, long game.
We're almost there.
The long, long game is almost over.
All right, here we are.
Here it is.
All right, 126.
Oh, I fucked up.
I forgot about the...
I forgot about the UFO.
The plan.
I had that plan already forgot about it.
Oh, it worked anyway.
I think I can...
You know what?
Send another...
Let's get that prize over there.
Oh my god, how long...
I've been pushing coins for four hours.
It's been four hours of pushing point.
Please let them please.
Okay.
I can't die!
It just can't die!
It's rude!
It refused to die!
Alright, 40 coins.
Grandpa, you're addicted.
How do I stop it?
Okay, that is...
Okay, we got this guy.
Oh, whoops.
That's good.
So I can...
Sell this prize, then.
Alright.
I'm just gonna try and look into pushing that guy over.
Alright, slow and steady.
all right question mark tab all right okay it's not all
right not the mask but good it's fine
okay all right i'm finally using my coins now my coins are
finally being used i'm just gonna use the ufo real quick all
right 18 out they pull me my back in son of a bitch i'm in
still at 10 percent
i might have to use the black hole
oh my god oh my god if i if i if i beat this right i'm
calling it here if i if i get to 3.2 e9
Endless.
Who would have thought?
Who would have thought the endless run is endless.
Oh my god.
Where did all these guys come from?
Okay.
We just need the mask.
We can literally end it all with the mask guys.
It's like that's all we We can end all this with just the
mask.
Oh, okay.
Just the mask in the tower.
Oh my god, it's almost not.
It's almost not.
Where are we?
Where the fuck are we?
Okay.
Okay, alright.
Screw badge.
Balance all.
Rich, dog.
Not the mask, but it's close enough.
Okay, fuck this.
We're gonna...
We're gonna send all these guys into the pit.
Okay.
The autofill is working over time.
We got that in.
Got this in
And then we sell this And then suck that up And then yo And
then refill And then oh come on Where is he?
I know you exist I Where are you?
The fastest size my fate It really does
We almost have another UFO coming in.
What's going on anymore?
I'm losing track.
How large one trillion actually is.
I'm tempted to send another black hole in here.
Fuck it.
get in here oh it's fine they refilled it
all right I'm sending another one in oh it's okay I got
another refill never punished I guess more black holes what
did I even roll into what did the wheel even give me I can't
even tell
Oh my god, it's still going.
Just give me that black hole.
Oh, okay.
Oh, do I have?
Alright, it's fine.
Oh, I got another black hole, guys.
I got two black holes.
I...
We still had three points.
If only we had a coin tower.
Oh, it's the mask!
It's the mask!
No.
Wait, wait.
This is it.
Everything lies on these guys!
Oh my god, there's two masks!
There's two masks!
Oh my god.
Yes!
We got it!
Oh my god!
They're stacking the tower!
Shit!
Oh my god!
The tower has been stacked!
Where am I?
What?
What's going on?
Don't flash, guys.
I'm almost there.
I where am I
Where even is this equation anymore And did I achieve the
goal?
Did I hit the game?
The game was like trying to catch up Even the game's
confused The game doesn't even know we're there yet He's
like are we there?
I can't tell I can't fucking tell okay okay okay all right
plus one prize stack limit okay guys I I don't know if I
could do another run I don't know is it over I don't No.
What is run data?
Where is run set yourself?
Free yourself to me.
You can't quit on a win streak.
I don't...
Wait, there's the magic bead.
But it's been so good to me.
silver paint for the magic bean is that worth selling silver
paint for the magic bean oh magic bean is bad no all right
keep silver I feel like I should just keep all my shit at
this point oh
my yeah we have it all right Your gambling is strong, stay
proud.
Oh my god.
I don't know if it'll ever end.
I don't know.
I just don't know if this will ever end.
I don't remember what my life was like before then.
What was it like?
I don't remember what life was it like before I can't tell
I don't remember what life was like guys
oh my god Oh my god, here it is Oh, you know what I'm gonna
do, guys Oh, I don't even need it Oh, there it is
Oh, and there guys
There it goes There it fucking goes Go, this one Wait I
blinked, was there a tower?
I don't know.
Did a tower exist?
Who knows?
Who fucking knows?
Life is a mystery.
Like, I'm just buying UFOs.
As you know the plot.
Oh my god, the wheel is glitching out now even the wheel is
like you're still going you're still I'm still playing I
want to know if there's an ending
Okay Maybe maybe I'll get to see the ending of the story
Okay There we go more UFOs How much to bribe you to end?
How much still on my first run?
You're looking crazy, Litter.
I'm more like, wow.
Well, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Okay, no prizes is where it's at.
We need prizes.
Prize makes the world go round.
The first over the kill screen in this game.
Okay.
Alright, $16.
Alright, nice.
And we sell the other one too.
And then just start sucking up.
And then the refill.
I just think I had the most ridiculous build to make this
work.
I don't even know how I did it.
Like, I legit thought this would be over.
I didn't think I, four hours later, I'll be here.
Oh, here we go.
Rich doll, balance doll.
They're still sending them in.
I just need the black hole.
I wish I still had my loop.
The crazy loop I had in the tutorial.
I think that one could have actually led me to the end.
I just kept getting infinite black holes.
I legit never had to move a single turn.
Maybe endless does mean endless.
And we're gonna...
Guys, it might be possible to...
Oh my god, there it is.
Guys, it might be possible, guys.
Like, we might...
We might die here.
There's a chance I'll be freed right here.
Guys, I think it's possible.
I might be free from my prison right here You can never die
Yes, I think I think I can see the ending at the tunnel
right here Oh my god Oh my god, the game really wants me to
get a mask It's like you'll never leave
They really want me to have the mask, guys.
Okay, okay, that's not a prize.
Could do a black hole right here, and he'll return me the
black hole.
Okay, I got this.
I got everything back.
Okay.
Guys, I just need the mask here, and then we'll be good to
go.
Okay, nice.
Okay, and I'll do the black hole here.
Oh, it's back.
Welcome back.
I'm glad you're here.
We want another black hole.
Oh, it's back.
Welcome back.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, 540.
all right we'll wait until in case there's more prizes i'm
just gonna wait until i can do anything still going all
right what did i get okay i got a rain oh my god is that no
that's oh my god oh no that there is there is yes Yes!
Okay, alright.
We turned.
Okay, now we're...
We did the long game.
With 540...
I blinked, Doki, what happened?
540 coins, by the way.
540 mass.
Yeah.
Alright, here we go again.
Okay, it's 13.
Alright.
I'm just gonna black hold this.
Like, I don't care.
Like, oh my god.
Who did they send over?
Alright.
Okay.
136 coins now.
Oh, oh, my God.
Is there a mask here?
Okay, no mask yet.
Not yet.
I can almost send it all on the right side.
The pod watcher skipped eight years.
They say she's still pushing coins to this day.
Legend says you might hear the sound of the coins dropping
down.
I've now become an urban legend.
Okay, here we go.
You just need another mask.
That 540 coin tower And the mask actually went so hard.
Okay, all right.
Where is it?
Okay, now we don't have...
All right.
Not yet.
The world isn't ready yet.
It's on cooldown.
Oh, hey, black hole.
I think I lost the black...
Oh, no, the black hole's right there.
All right, who are you?
Oh, yeah.
Alright, nice.
And we're gonna need that black holster.
Alright.
Let's just grab that in two real quick.
Alright, nice to be off.
I actually need that a lot.
Thank god I had the autofill shit.
Like that would have been crazy.
I had to do all that without the autofill.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Alright.
Auto-fill that for me, sir.
125.
I think we would have definitely died a lot earlier if the
birds stopped coming.
We could technically sell a coin.
Just to keep it going.
He had saved me from ending before endless.
Yeah.
It really did.
Wait for the next episode of Coin Pusher for...
run we're hunting for the mask be very very quiet okay it's
okay we'll just keep let's just keep Chucky coin I even have
the fact that I have an infinite mud coin glitch too like I
don't even have to worry about my coin situation it just it
just keeps going A fucking infinite coin glitch.
Okay, here we go.
Here's another one.
Alright.
UFO time.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
168.
If only we had it.
Alright, we're just gonna leave it.
Let him stack.
Alright, nice.
Oh.
Oh my god.
How am I even gonna get there?
E11?
Okay, E11.
I can't believe I could play this game for four fucking
hours.
Oh my god.
I actually saw less than four.
400 coins.
I didn't think that would be possible.
I I didn't think I didn't think I could see that see that
that's a real thing under 400 coins what reality am I in if
I cut this wait oh shit bye coins Oh, I'm so smart.
I was just like...
Oh, okay.
Alright, we have the black hole at least.
We'll grab the black hole while we're at it.
I just had to get that tower out.
Alright.
Fuck it.
Just send them back in.
Like, send that back in.
To the depths of hell.
Or another tower.
Oh my god.
Get that other tower in.
Now it was in a waste.
Oh my god.
I'm back at the 400 again.
I thought I was out of it.
Alright, there it is.
Goodbye tower.
Oh my god, come on.
And now it's just sending me coins, which I'm not
complaining, but like, with this, the strat we have, we
don't need coins right now with this strat.
Yeah, it was a very short tower.
Okay, we're close to another...
Okay, nice.
I do need...
32.
Good morning from Germany.
Good morning, Tuget.
Good morning.
We're still here.
You know, I'm sending the giraffe in.
Fuck it.
Go, go do your thing, giraffe.
Have the time of your life.
I mean, go wild.
Oh, shit.
Alright, rich dog.
Oh my god.
Alright, send that in.
I'm just gonna start selling coins.
I don't need the other coins.
I'm here to play the log game.
Okay.
Four.
Yeah, we need to grab those.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, black hole!
Okay, a white hole.
Okay, we need that.
Alright, nice.
And nice, more UFOs.
That's what we needed.
Sell more.
My 70% isn't working anymore, though, which is concerning
because the whole strat is so I could keep refilling my
prizes.
Okay.
I'm not going to throw anymore because I need to...
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Is that...
Oh, come on.
Come on!
We need the mask!
Please!
This is my time strat.
Free me.
Free me from this eternal damnation.
Okay.
It's fine.
I'll have the UFO coming in.
I'm not getting the question mark, which isn't great.
My RNG for it has been bad now.
I'm going to try and grab the one to the right so I can sell
that.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Okay.
We're going to grab plus five.
It needs to be plus.
You're being cursed by this run because everyone, this one.
It's gonna be chasing this hot.
Thank you for the super chat, Phileon.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, here we go.
Come on.
Question mark.
Question.
God!
Oh, I have to let the prize this drop.
That's my bad.
I've been...
Oh my god.
Wait, I think... I think this could end.
I think this could end.
Oh my god.
Guys, this might...
I might be freed.
Guys, there is a chance I might be freed.
My coins.
They're losing value.
There's hope.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm actually losing coins now.
I'm not gaining coins.
There is actual.
in this world the freedom is coming all right it's fine it's
fine okay oh it's a question mark oh this better be oh my
god it's okay it's okay oh my god I'm Under 300.
I'm under 300, guys.
Guys, I'm under 300.
No, don't you promise you'll stay here, friend.
Oh my God.
We're under 300.
I didn't know that number existed.
What are these?
Okay.
We actually might make it.
We're actually, like, getting really bad RNG.
It's actually possible.
Oh my god, we're going to be freed from our eternal
damnation.
Okay.
It's okay.
Alright, it's back again.
Okay, it's okay.
All right, good?
Go ahead, just give us coins.
Keep giving us coins.
We've actually made it.
The spit.
Even the game is tired.
Freedom is finally coming.
Even the game wants this to end.
Oh my god.
It's coming!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, where are we at?
Where's Jason?
Is this balance?
Rich pause.
Screw.
Rich.
Balance.
Oh my god.
I'm...
Okay.
Oh my god.
Screw that.
Okay, there you go.
Alright, we've re- I think this is purgatory.
I- This actually might be purgatory.
Not gonna lie.
I think I've seen what purgatory is.
Okay, there we go.
We got the white- we got what I wanted.
Oh, please.
How?
Alright.
I've rebuilt my fortune.
I've...
I've rebuilt my fortune, guys.
We loot back the 300.
Okay.
Screw badge.
Black hole.
Okay, it's five.
It's absolutely five.
All we need is that black hole right there.
That's all we need.
Okay, God, I got the black hole.
I got the black hole.
Is this LG or are you playing?
There you is.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's here.
It's here.
It's actually here.
Okay, we gotta do this very carefully, guys.
We have to do this.
Oh my god, there's two of them!
Okay.
We have to do this very carefully.
Oh my god.
It's right here.
Yes!
Okay.
All right, anything glows from here on out.
Everything.
All right.
Okay, anything goes now.
Anything goes.
Okay.
I gotta grab two.
All right, here we go.
We lost.
We're back.
We're like, I'm sorry to see why you don't like have like
these.
It just doesn't.
What can I do?
Wait,
it doesn't stop!
Okay.
Alright.
I'm just gonna sell this real quick because I want that
black wolf.
She's just too good.
Just when I thought, I just made money.
I thought it was over and then, and now I'm at $500 almost.
Chris, forever in the cab, that's punishment.
I'm gonna just use it.
Just fuck it.
Now we just need another tower.
We have the mask.
I stopped the loop, though, guys.
I ended the...
Oh!
I was like, as I stopped the prize loop, what level of dodge
is infertile did I walk to?
I'm gonna say it's end, it's over.
I stopped the prize loop, but we never stopped.
And the loop doesn't stop.
I ran, thank you for the super chat, Thank you, thank you.
It's fine.
Alright, we sold another one.
We just need another mask.
Come on.
Throw that one in.
Alright, throw that one in.
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
There's our little guy.
Just match the W.
Oh, there's our favorite little guy.
$32.
We have two masks now.
All right.
We're going to wait a little bit before we send anything in.
Okay.
Put that in here.
And put another UFO.
And then, boom.
And then we made it.
The game was like, please wait.
Vodwatches skip 30 years.
Where are we at?
Where has life taken us?
Down.
Oh, we're...
Where has...
Where has life taken us?
Wait, what?
How am I here?
Where am I?
Oh my god, there's another mask.
Let's get that.
Let's get that right now.
We might as well, it's over here.
All right, nice.
Oh, hey, but guys, he shall never leave Klois Plisher.
Okay, we just need a tower.
Guys, it's gonna end, it's gonna, I swear to god it will end
guys this will see the ending we're gonna i swear to god
we're gonna see the ending guys i can feel it i know it's
gonna end see this is why joki didn't go to evil vegas in
person.
She would never be there.
She would still be there winning today.
Thank you for the Super Chat Cog.
Thank you.
It's gonna end!
I swear!
I don't get it.
It's been four hours.
We're just free us from this hell.
It's gonna end!
I swear!
Look at GTA 6, where Doki finishes her first run of
Rackpoint.
Oh my god, we're at 360 now.
There it is.
Oh my god, where are we?
No mask
Takey-toe, freak it by watching this stream I've kicked my
gambling addiction today Let the coins flow for each turn
It's going to end I swear We'll see the ending Watching an
end right here.
You had some math.
Why did you use it, Doki?
I don't know.
It's all blurring together, guys.
It's...
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Alright.
Mike, thank you.
Super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Guys, I come from the future.
He is at 1.1.
Is this also a match?
Oh my god, there it is.
There he is.
Is this freedom?
No, we're back.
That's what you know you're actually in hell.
It gave you a taste of freedom for one second and then pulls
you right back in.
And then you wake up.
Release me, Mike, thank you for the super chat, thank you,
thank you.
That's when you know you're here forever.
Let us out.
We're all, but guys, this is it, this is the run.
Brady, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
set us free guys this is it i swear if this is gonna be the
run kiaaku thank you with a super chat thank you thank you
all right this is it this is the run guys we'll be set free
here so this is it
free!
Alright, anyway, we're back here.
At this point, I'm just buying this repunishment.
You're here forever.
Oh no, a bad coin.
What am I going to do now?
Put the red button.
Oh no, what am I possibly gonna do about a bad coin?
Oh no.
Oh, nothing bad happens to me.
I really hope nothing bad happens to me.
Release us from this orbit.
Another plus A, let's go.
This time, this is where the run dies, guys.
This is it.
This is where it dies.
I believe.
This is where they'll set us free.
This is a PSA.
This is a PSA to stop gambling.
One must imagine Doki having.
This is the guys.
This is the run.
This is the run where we're freed.
I do not believe you.
Please stop giving me fall.
So Doki, you said that eight rounds ago.
But this is it.
We're at 2.3 E.
15.
It cannot go further than that.
No way.
Don't gamble too much, kids.
Or you'll win.
Or you'll win too much.
Right here.
We'll be freed from eternal damnation.
This is it on round 15.
My UFO isn't working.
I've not had a break since.
I can give it up for E15.
Oh, I imagine I could convert this to real money.
Welcome to the halfway point, Fod Rogers.
You're almost there.
Oh my god.
I've had so many bad rolls, though, that I haven't been able
to get more prizes since.
I've just been, surprisingly, guys, guys, this might be it.
Guys, guys, I think this actually might be it.
I've ran out of prizes.
I have not had a single prize roll, guys.
I think, I think this is it.
I think this is it, guys.
Okay.
We're on.
Oh, never mind.
Rewind.
It's rewind time.
Okay.
Alright, 72 tower.
Don't she lies as easily as she can, but...
Okay.
That's five.
Don't worry.
We're coming in hot.
With more prizes.
Coming in hot with more prizes, guys.
My classes are finished.
First run.
Guys, first run.
We're still in it.
Guys, we can't just mask it.
I need to wait.
Make sure I have two masks.
I can't just waste my mask on a mask with only one mask.
Are you guys crazy?
Alright, here we go.
Alright, we got another one.
Oh, and then it refunded itself.
I'm just gonna wait.
I'm gonna wait for it.
I don't want to put more coins in.
I gotta roll it.
Here we go.
We are surprised when running out of now we have been having
some bad rolls oh
it's this oh hey it's back they've only been giving me coins
so that's a good sign chat this is a good sign breaking new
signs I found the cure of gambling they strapped the patient
into the chair and forced them to watch the VOD
You can never leave.
Period.
You're stuck here forever.
You're only at part one of the VODs.
We've hit the 12-hour limit.
We started it at part two.
It matches.
Not stopping until this runs over.
Okay.
Oh, I like how these two keep coming back to me.
They're like, oh, we're back guys.
What happened?
Oh, hey, we got new friends.
New friends to restart the run with.
Isn't that great?
Oh, one of them left.
They did not come back.
Oh, he came back, though.
Alright.
Well, I haven't got question mark yet.
Do we think I get question mark by now?
The amount of rolls I've done.
I think the worst part is that I think I my items are not
like the most optimal so it takes so long to get to the end
like I don't know if my items are even optimal not gonna lie
for any of this they are so so it's like we're crawling to
the end too.
I don't make it but slow.
That makes it more painful.
You have infinite sustain but no score.
I feel like I should sell Rack going to economics.
I don't think I'll ever use the exchange.
Okay.
Oh, there they are.
I'll trust, yeah, I realized I should have sold this a long
time ago.
I just made it worse for you guys.
It's literally slow to prolong the suffering.
That's the best part, though.
That's what makes it even more fun.
Holy shit!
What happened?
Where did all these prizes come from?
Where did all these things...
My god.
Alright.
Then we can keep going.
All right, we keep going though, isn't that great?
We keep going, everyone.
We're not even at E1 yet.
Guys, it's because we're waiting on the mask.
Just wait until the mask is here and it'll all be worth it.
Oh my god, when will I get my question mark?
Keep going forever.
And never, and never.
Oh my god, the prizes actually stopped.
It's time for me to go work.
Good luck, Jokia.
See y'all in the fun.
Thank you for the super chat, Jokia.
Thank you.
No, hey!
Hey!
I don't think I've seen a question mark yet.
Alright.
Oh, here's another UFO.
Oh, 90 coins saved us from more prizes.
We're only at like 0.1% technically.
Is it gonna spin?
Alright.
Oh, there is!
There is!
These are here!
Okay, okay, okay, we're good.
We're good.
We're good, we're good.
We gotta, we gotta get him up the- We gotta- We gotta get
him from the other side!
Where did he go?
Oh my god, he's right here.
He's right here.
Move him closer!
Someone move him closer!
Save us!
Oh my god!
Someone move this guy closer!
Oh my god, it's sucking it up.
I can't even...
Oh my god.
Oh my...
Okay, right here, right here.
Right here.
Wait, I got another one.
I actually got another one.
I'm still...
Okay.
I know we might as well suck this up.
Since we're here.
Did I make...
The high score seems to be earned by player in rounds.
The goal was 9.5 each.
I don't know How long did he play for?
How far did he get?
I don't even know how far I'm at
Where am I?
Okay You got a long way to go UFO has not left work You're
almost there.
There is...
Alright.
He's still showing up so we're...
Oh my god.
And then I play Pot of Greed!
There's any...
Pricester are coins.
And I shall put another Pot of Greed!
Oh, yeah, she's the only immortal build.
It's just a matter of time.
Alright, who are you?
I think it stops.
Okay, I think it stops now.
I think it stops now.
Okay, I think it stops.
Okay, I think it stops now
Okay, I'm at 999 coins It stops guys It finally stops Oh my
god
It's never going to stop and you know a thousand you played
the last of all the planets the gamba rode it away
completely it's not like the last surviving human being on
this planet the world is just AI watch they preserved me
just so the AI preserved me just to see how far I'm gonna go
just wanted to see when the gamba ends for science Oh my god
Oh my god I've finally lost all the prizes Oh Rewind time
With just the voices in your head The fact that I've made it
to a thousand points The most unoptimal run Most unoptimal
build, but because I can't die, we're just here for the rest
of our lives.
All right, here we go.
Unoptimal yet unstoppable.
Come on, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, hey, Jokey, happy birthday.
Oh, we're still playing Rackwood.
That's cool.
Part 20 of Rackwood.
I'm just wondering, the high score guy, like, I think he
stopped just because he just can't play this game.
Like, his PC died or something.
There's no way he stopped it by, like, there's no way he
actually lost a game.
It was, like, a choice to just stop playing.
Onward to victory.
What is victory?
I think we are lost.
I think it was Super Chat.
Thank you.
He stopped because, yeah, he stopped because.
he was just too old.
He can't play anymore.
No way.
Oh, there they go.
Mask it?
Alright.
Oh my god.
Oh, hey, new coins.
Oh, what?
Well, I should just shake that down.
Is there another mask anywhere?
No, alright.
How many towers are you gonna need?
Yes.
Oh.
I'm just gonna sell this.
And I'm gonna sell that.
I'm gonna sell this.
And then...
How are you still...
I'm still on my first run.
Hey, Joke, you still a recording game too?
Are you gonna do commentary at this World Cup?
Oh!
I'm just gonna suck this.
surely that would do something
oh where am i at just keep sucking
oh all right coin all right suck again
oh my god just spin the wheel please it's never gonna stop
just spin it and just spin the wheel
oh my god please it's just not gonna stop the prizes are
just gonna keep coming
all right there you go oh my god please just give me a
question mark please that's all i asked for i just put a
question mark oh my god the ufo can't do anything he just
exists
okay it stopped it finally stopped
She went from ball and gun gamer to gambling gamer.
I'm a thousand two hundred that's okay.
I didn't even realize it would go that high.
If I shoot the dog, will it stop?
I have to take it into my own hands.
Use the coins, I thank you.
Oh my god, question mark!
Question mark!
Oh my god.
Here comes another big boy.
Here he is.
Here comes a big boy.
All right.
Oh, we're always so close to more...
Some more mass.
All right.
So...
Maybe this run will end.
Guys.
Maybe it'll end, y'all.
Guys, maybe it'll end here, guys.
Guys.
Maybe it'll end here.
Guys, I'm going to use up all that money is going to go
away.
Oh.
It's going to end here, guys.
It's going to end here.
When?
Don't keep.
Guys, it's going to end here.
It's going to end here.
As long as you have coins in your head, please free us.
Right here.
We're almost there guys.
I can't see
the horizon, the sun exploded.
We ran out of prize.
this surely this is where it ends we ran out of prizes
surely oh why does it keep giving me coins give me a mask
why don't i just keep spinning coins out it would free us
okay do not give her a mask Guys, imagine.
Just imagine we got a mask, though.
Where's your spirit, Doki?
You know we can't end in the last guy doing a new round
after this.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck is it?
Oh.
Here comes the tower.
Okay.
Please, no more prize.
No more prizes.
Here comes another prize.
I
got it.
Here comes another one.
I think the worst part is the fact that I'm not getting more
prize rolls or question marks.
I'm literally just giving me infinite coins.
I don't know what's worse.
When you play Starcraft Reborn, keep playing Recon, if yet.
Thank you for the super chat.
I hate this.
Thank you.
Thank you guys guys.
This is it.
This is the last run This is where I die Surely this is
where I die guys.
This is it right here Oh My god, why is it all the rich
dogs?
What is this RNG?
Why is it just these guys?
okay
oops all dogs it's just all dogs is there a way to end this
like can I can I just leave yeah
what did I get all right I threw a mask okay no it's just
it's just more umbrellas I blame Snuffy for don't use
chaffling addiction.
Oh my god, it's five hours.
It's been five hours.
Oh my god.
Oh, spin that wheel.
Spin that wheel.
Okay, that UFO coming in again.
We literally just need one more mask and we have not found a
single fucking mask.
We got everything plus the mask.
Oh, fuck, okay.
What is that?
Nope, not the mask.
Dude, that's all we need.
That's really all we need.
We'll be freed.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
I don't need more coins.
I have a thousand two hundred.
I have a thousand two.
I don't need more.
Oh They just keep throwing more pride Oh here we go Here we
go It's one of them the mask Dark cat evens down Okay we
have black holes out It's close enough That's like the mask
Okay It's almost like the mask Oh my god What number am I on
What is that number
At this point, I just have to end it on my own turn.
It's
a 16.5 score rate.
Oh my god.
Like, I don't even need the...
I should have just sold Moon Knight Kitlan.
Why did you make...
Why did I not sell these two?
Joking my child just gradually.
in college or a docker and they wanted me to sell you thank
you for playing right the way it says for words thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you why did i make the
most unoptimal build the most sustainable unoptimal build in
existence ips thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you This is your mother speaking.
I did not raise a quitter.
You better gamble forever.
Our ancestors demand this.
Also, I brought you cut oranges.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
A bag.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Okay, at this point, you might want to cancel that vacation.
I don't think you're leaving for that point.
Why did I bite?
I'm just trapped in a turtle hell.
Oh my god.
When will I ever see a question mark?
Okay.
Surely I'll get a question mark here, right?
Surely.
Oh my god.
This has finally stopped.
Alright, Rich Dog.
Welcome back, Rich Dog.
It's like you never left, Rich Boy.
Cozy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We're below 1,400.
We have a chance.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm getting below 1,300, guys.
Guys, there's hope.
There's hope.
We're almost out of it.
Okay.
We just gotta keep spamming it.
Okay, okay.
Alright, we're getting really bad rolls, which is good for
us, guys.
That's good for us.
Remember, that's really good.
If we get bad rolls...
At this point you just leave the game running go to bed will
still be going.
I wish there was an auto wait I could take I wish I could
have like an auto play function just to see how long it goes
I thought thank you for chatting thank you
Oh my god you have 1.3 that's the lowest we've ever got you
can't I know you're very surprised that I know you're trying
to say as if that's a lot of money But that's the lowest
we've ever We haven't seen our coins that low in so long.
For us, for us, that's hope.
This is auto-play.
Guys, thank you, Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
All this could have been avoided.
Don't keep, just remain.
Hated, rocker, raccoon.
You know, Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh, my God.
Guys, we might actually move this down to 1,000.
coins guys guys i know i said like before to stop to that's
where we can hope now but this this is where we can start
hoping again right here this this is it guys this is where
the hope is it's right here
below a thousand it's possible we can see a number go below
a thousand
it's possible it's possible guys where is this it's possible
I need that I need the white old uh this is the most
effective anti-gallic PSA I've ever seen you're so bright
here there's hope they just keep giving me coins instead of
i i think i rolled like 80 times and i've only seen the one
question mark
that's cubic thank you with a super chat thank you thank you
come on give me that roll
oh okay all right black hole black hole that's good that's
good we need the black hole It speeds things up a little bit
for us.
That's what we wanted.
Baby, that's what we wanted.
Okay.
Let me see if...
All right, that's fine.
That is okay.
We don't...
Still no...
Still no mask, but that is okay.
That is...
That is okay.
see the mask anywhere.
There's a lot of... Oh my gosh.
That's okay.
This is where... Alright.
Still no mask, but that's okay.
We got like five rolls at once.
Okay.
Joki hasn't streamed in a minute, so I've paid for an
unhealthy amount of Joki.
I guess this one's on me.
Be careful what you win for.
Cyber, thank you for this new chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's Monkey Faw, girl.
I think that's the worst part of the score hasn't even
moved.
All right.
We've really truly been stuck.
Oh my god, just one mask I've been rolling, I've been
pushing points For like Oh my god, or any of those I can't
even know I swear to god If a mask literally fell down I
couldn't see Because there were so many funny things On my
trees Oh my god I think I've been throwing coins in here for
like an hour straight and I haven't seen a single mess.
We used to swim in masks, guys.
Okay.
It's all right.
Get these guys out of the way.
Okay.
Here we go.
oh gosh are any of these no did i like hit the mask limit
just not gonna generate it anymore like they're like we
didn't think you're gonna
stop the generation oh we're back to 1400 i didn't even
notice that how do we get here Oh my god, I can't even tell
anymore.
At this point, Nintendo Power gonna be friends before Tokyo
finishes this game.
Yeah, I'm good.
Thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
I didn't know we were surprised we haven't even moved up a
number.
Oh.
It hasn't been a bad time.
I feel like it's like an urban legend now.
Are you sure we saw it, guys?
Guys, are we sure we even saw the mask?
Are you even sure it ever existed?
I can't even tell.
How do we know if it's actually real, guys?
How do we even know?
Oh my god, it's still going.
My 100,000 tickets.
Oh my god, I don't even know what's real or not anymore.
I don't even know.
Oh, it's just gonna keep giving me coins.
And with the mask, it's just the story we tell.
It was a gasp.
leak hello
miss jokie bird my father told me to continue watching this
trade said it was his legacy for me you seem very fun so
i'll try my best solid snake thank you in the super chat
thank you thank you ah he was there when we hit 750 000
those were the good old days
when we had the chance remember when we almost died there
and then again if we had almost died there we've been over
oh my god i haven't hit a question mark in so long i don't
even think it exists anymore oh my god we're below 1400
we're below 40 guys Guys, we're below 1,400, I guess.
Please just roll, just roll.
Nothing is gonna come down, just roll.
Just roll.
Oh,
another tower.
A black hole.
How neat.
That's what I've always wanted.
Another black hole.
But listen to this, I asked to go to the other place, only
discovered he was already there.
That crimson thing, you have a super chat, thank you, thank
you.
Thank you.
Oh.
Oh, I don't need more coins.
I don't need more coins.
We don't need more coins!
Shadows, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
But Doki, what if we had more coins?
Doki, what if that was so funny?
The ghost shirt that you was super sticker.
Thank you.
Oh.
Oh my god, just send these prizes over.
Just send these prizes.
Oh my god, oh my god, we're below 1400.
We're below 1400.
Guys, guys, we're below 1400.
This is it.
This is it!
We're getting bad luck right now.
We're getting bad runs!
oh my god oh my god we're getting below a thousand we get
below thousand guys we're getting bad luck right now we're
getting actual bad luck it's happening oh
my god i think they i think i've actually hit the limit i i
didn't know who it was possible but i think It's like the
fucking black the black holes not like the mass limit.
I didn't know that existed
No, oh Okay, okay, we ought to be very careful with this
Okay
We got to be super careful.
We got to be super careful with this we got to plan this
correctly
That's the red it's the red it's the red
Okay, okay We got planned this very carefully We got Oh,
come on
Yes!
Oh my god Oh my god Oh my god, it's here Oh, it's here Okay,
okay, this is the plan This is the plan All right, the plan,
we do the plan now.
We do the plan now.
Oh my god.
No more.
Please don't get so tight.
Okay, but like, what should we get?
Okay, how do I stop?
How do I...
Okay.
How do I get out of here?
Why?
Okay, but guys, we can make our build more optimal.
Yes, guys.
We can get the...
We can make it more optimal, guys.
Guys, we can make the build so optimal.
Guys, guys, think about it.
Please, my guys, guys, guys, guys, we can make the build so
optimal.
Guys, guys, guys, guys, think about this.
Guys, guys.
You
nodding.
It's so true.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
and 20 modified cards.
I don't know if we should do this.
And congrats to Future Tokyo, 1.0 E6 subs and reaching 2.3
E16 points for a Stokie soon to be passed.
Thank you for this gamba PSA Future Tokyo is awesome,
please.
that I can look after for us.
Drag boots.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, guys, we can make this so optimal.
You get your good luck.
I mean, good night, Jokey.
Best first, here you go.
Space, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What all the plaza traps are, what all the stars in the
night sky with it away.
When the universe turns into nothingness this obsession left
to win this at don't you let's still be there optimizing her
build guys guys guys oh my god guys guys guys guys we can we
can optimize this birdie i just think guys i just think i'll
optimize this Bill can get it!
Just think!
We're so close to optimization!
Dude, just think about it!
We're so close!
Okay.
We're so close to peak optimization!
We really are!
Okay.
Oh my god, just think, just think, guys.
Just think.
He's 17.
It's just, guys, just, just think, guys.
Just think.
Just think about it.
Oh my god, is that a white hole and a black hole?
Oh my god.
Okay, we gotta get that.
We gotta get those.
Okay, nice.
Okay, we got that.
Guys, peak optimization.
Guys, guys, peak optimization right now.
We're doing peak optimization.
We're back in the fucking building.
Oh We still Oh my
god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, guys He's
right here, he's right here, he's right here, he's right
here, he's right here He's right here
I never thought it'd come to this cyber thank you for the
super chat but guys guys he's right here he's right here
he's right here right now
guys look at this look at look at this though look at look
at this
we're optimizing we're optimizing we're we're optimizing
guys look at the optimizing guys guys guys look at the look
at the optimization look at how optimized we are let me not
do it again these numbers aren't real are any of us real is
anything real maybe this is all over we can go back to
clicking down Swimpy thank you for the super chat thank you
guys guys we're so optimized are you look at how optimized
we are right now do you guys see it do you guys see the
optimization though do you see it i need to know if you are
aware of the optimized i need to know i need to know if you
are aware i need to know
it's amazing i don't even want to look anymore but do you
see the optimization you're not answering my question though
you see how optimized we are
Do you see it, though?
I need to know you see it.
Question mark.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, it's fine.
We can get another one.
How much does it give?
Okay, that's fine.
We don't need that.
It's okay.
I just need to keep sending it over.
I think it could be more optimized.
You're so right, guys.
You're so right.
I'm sending more in.
Oh my god, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I might be able to...
Guys, I might be able to bring us freedom.
Guys, guys, guys, this might be...
I've never seen it under 100 coins before.
What is that?
That's a goddamn tax doll.
Okay, what's gonna fall down?
Oh my god, the fucking dog.
Oh my god, I don't think I've ever...
I don't think I've ever seen...
My money under 200 is so long.
But that's a myth.
Oh my god, it's actually possible.
It's actually possible.
Set us free, Doki.
Set us free.
And I need coins.
Oh my god.
This is it.
Under a hundred.
Under a hundred dollars.
This might be it.
Freedom is there.
Freedom is actually so close.
Freedom actually exists.
I'm just gonna do that.
I don't care.
How long does that be?
It's now I'm eating dinner.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you guys.
We're 100 coins.
We're below 100 coins.
Oh my god, we're below 100 coins.
We are below, I repeat, we are below 100 coins.
We're seeing numbers we haven't seen before.
We're back 100 coins.
Oh my god.
The only way to escape this is another mask.
It's the only way we'll be freed.
But they won't do this to us, guys.
We're going to be freed.
Oh, we're no longer under 100.
We are no longer under.
Who said the towel?
We are...
We are above 200, guys.
We are now above 200.
I repeat.
I'm lost in the coin tower.
Someone police said help.
We're almost there, guys.
This is the strongest torture.
You were already dead.
This is, you're stuck in hell.
Your hell is just watching me push.
boys until the end of time.
You keep climbing up instead of going down.
I was thinking it was so funny.
It went from 100 to 1000 instantly.
But I didn't mean that.
We were at some 100.
Oh my god.
Why did we find the dog food why did we do it why didn't we
buy the dog food how could we have
Don't!
Oh, I still don't see the bats.
And that tries to warn us.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
I couldn't even tell!
If the mask was even there, it went by so fast.
I couldn't even see it.
Couldn't even tell if it showed up!
God, I hope there's no mask in this pile!
No, there isn't.
We're safe.
We're safe for now.
Oh my god!
I sure hope the mask didn't fucking collapse into the pile!
Okay.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
Let's just use that real quick.
Alright, that's okay.
That's alright.
Okay, 100 coins is all we need.
More black coal, that's fine.
Just suck that up.
Oh, another one's driving work.
Well, it's my Kamiyoshi suffering from good luck.
What a time.
to be a lot.
I definitely did not go up the number.
I definitely did not go up any numbers right now.
Another refill?
Oh, see, it ain't so.
Let's go!
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh, I'm at 500 coins.
Guys, remember when we had 100 coins?
Those were the good old days when we had 100 coins.
Guys, I forgot how that was possible.
Oh, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't keep doing
this.
I can't keep doing this.
I can't keep doing this!
I can't!
I...
I can't keep doing it!
I can't!
I'm going nuclear.
I can't do this anymore.
I can't.
Oh, I can't get me out of here.
Just stop.
Stop.
I need to do this.
Do you keep it chat-offs?
Oh my god!
Oh my god, don't do this to me.
You can't just push it, just push it to me.
Do this anymore!
Why won't it end?
Why?
I want it to end!
Make it stop.
There's no more safety net.
It ends here!
It's just my turn still has an end in here.
yet.
How is this still my turn?
How?
How is it still my turn?
It's just autoplay.
It's over.
Is it over?
I believe this let it continue.
I'm trying!
The game is playing itself!
Oh my god.
Does that turn walk in infinity?
Is the turn over?
Is the turn...
Oh my god.
Is it...
Is the turn over?
Is that chuck everything in?
Chuck it all in!
Oh my god.
It should open.
Just, just end it.
Just end it!
Okay.
Well, I should want that white hole though.
Just so I could do that.
Oh!
I just really wanted to do that.
You don't understand?
You were too authorized.
No, Doki!
Why?
That's it, that's it, that should be it.
No, we understand.
Let's just try to optimize, guys.
One last optimization.
You understand, right?
You guys understand, right?
One last optimization for the run.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Let's see, T.
We're almost to the end.
We're almost to the end, guys.
It's almost over.
It's almost.
The end is next.
It's almost here.
It's almost here again.
Oh, shit.
Is it over?
One last suck for the ride One second last suck for the ride
That one last suck for the ride Real
Oh my god Well
then Oh, well, that's awkward.
I mean,
I can't...
What was I supposed to buy?
We're so bad.
You guys,
how was I supposed to know?
How was I supposed to know?
Okay, now, now it should be over.
Okay, now, now it should be almost done.
The tower is up.
I shook, I had to shake the tower.
Alright, this should be, this should be, This should be the
last.
This should be the ending.
This should be how it ends.
We have no more items.
We almost have no more items.
It's like...
This is how it goes.
We're at the final countdown now.
Oh my god.
This is how it ends.
We're at the final countdown.
For real now.
The last three items.
Right here.
The last.
The last item.
Okay, wait.
Wait.
This is it, guys.
last coin this is it guys last three coins one two three
it's over it's over it's finally over
it's finally oh my god it's finally over
I couldn't I can't I can't I can't keep going anymore if you
want to take my take the sea that you can't I just can't I
can't do this anymore I can't I can't do it anymore just I
see my kids again where did I go Locked everything.
Shadows, thank you.
That was my first run.
That was my first run, guys.
That, I've only done one run.
I, I had to take, I had to leave by my own terms.
Running back, thank you.
Thank you for the super chance, thank you, thank you.
I had to, I had to take it out on my own terms.
I couldn't do this anymore.
I knew I knew I knew I knew it would never end I had the
most sustainable but inefficient build ever I took myself
out oh we did it we did it again poverty thank you for the
super chat Thank you.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
I think I could actually this run who I've gone on forever.
If I legitimately was not a streamer.
And I just kept playing.
And then leave my piece like.
Just kept going.
For like 10 years.
I think this.
I don't think I would have ever died.
There was no way to lose.
There was actually no way to lose in the build I have.
But it was definitely the most inefficient build you can
ever get.
It's you, Kate.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I hope we're having that work safely.
Have a great day, everyone.
Finally, we are to do it.
Do it again.
Elkis, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sweet embrace of Thank you.
Valhalla, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're free.
We're free now.
We're alive.
Okay.
We made it out of hell.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm gonna call it.
I'm two streams tomorrow.
Yes.
I didn't think.
it would oh my god tomorrow is another rogue like it's it's
how many dudes where you're like how many dudes does it take
to beat up a gorilla like it's another rogue like i did not
think this this i just want to see how long my first run's
gonna endless was truly endless i did not who would have
thought endless run is is an endless run who would have
thought oh i i just wanted to see the ending but i realized
there was no ending there never was going to be an ending
i'm gonna call it here as always everybody say hi join the
pause check up move around and get that blood flow you
stayed up for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see
you guys next time everybody bye guys bye